[Music]
with two rounds in the books
eight of the best players on the planet
were back to do battle
in the hunt for the title tournament
leader ian nepomniacci
extended his lead with a big win against
fellow russian karil alexenko
and now stands a full point ahead of his
main rivals with only four rounds to go
it's the round after the rest day and
the players are refreshed and ready to
fight to the bitter end
round 11 coverage of the candidates in
yekaterinburg russia starts now
[Music]
welcome everybody it is round 11 of the
candidates to determine
the challenger to magnus carlsen for the
world championship
we are bringing you the action that is
taking place at the hyatt regency in
yekaterinburg and what a tournament
we've had
so far full of drama full of incidents
my name is alejandra ramirez i'm here
with grand masters maurice ashley and
yasser sarawan
to bring you all the action of today
yasser
what a bunch of rounds we've had but a
clear leader and what a favorite he is
right now
absolutely good good afternoon everyone
uh we have had a free day a much
needed free day because i gotta tell you
that the tournament has been
so tense and those uh starting rounds
really kept me on the edge of
my seat and yes our tournament leader
nepo he's looking really really good at
the moment to become the next challenger
maurice
yes after three rounds what more could
you want a point lead
on the rest of the field with only four
rounds to go remember
only seven rounds to play so everybody
came in feeling they needed a quick
start
everyone got one at least fabi did anish
did
mvl not so much but nepo got what the
doctor ordered in round three
and i don't know guys if i were a
betting man for this event
it looks like nepo is very much in the
driver's seat
let's take a look at the standings
alejandro it's yande pomnyachis we've
been talking about the man of the hour
six and a half
points that puts him a full point of
that out of that hungry pack
maxine bashar lagrave fabiano karana and
anish giri
all within striking distance just a
point difference
but can they make it up in so few rounds
wang hao and alexander grisjr with four
and a half points
not mathematically eliminated but pretty
much while dingley wren and kirill
alexenko
they're not gonna be fighting for the
first place in this tournament
let's take a look at the format it is of
course a double round robin of which the
first round robin was played
last year a very classical chess 100
minutes for the first 40 moves
50 minutes for the next 20 and of course
at move 60 you get another 15 minutes
for the rest of the game something we've
actually seen a few times already
in this second half of the round robin
all throughout you get a
30 second increment uh so that's a very
long games
no draw offers before black's 40th move
and a 500 000 euro prize fund which as
we
all know it pales in comparison to that
ticket to the world championship
in dubai later this year let's take a
look at the schedule
as we just came out of our first rest
day
we have around today around tomorrow and
we will have our second rest day
the players will resume on april 26 and
27th with games 13
and 14 probably to finish off the
tournament as playoffs are
unlikely remember that mathematical
playoffs in this tournament
take precedence over uh over the board
playoffs
those will not be necessary unless every
single mathematical one is tied which is
extremely unlikely but there are there
will be some scenarios in which that
happens
maurice what is going on with the four
players that can take this tournament
well indeed we have been talking about
the big four so far
and rightfully so it doesn't look like
anyone else
could possibly pull off a miracle in
order to come back
and let's take a look at these players
because they have their
hopes pinned on how the road ahead goes
aneesh giri to start we saw him with a
big win
against wang hao he's got these four
players including dingler in today
caruana tomorrow that will indeed be a
big game
and then two players who are pretty much
out of it gristrok and aksenko
they know he'll be hunting for them will
he be able to pull off
some big wins in order to close the gap
against nepal
remember he actually lost to nepo
earlier in the event so he's gonna have
to do even more
to tie him or to defeat him i should say
fabiana carwana
also with nepo this round with his
aspirations he gets geary tomorrow
and then wang hao and grisham but look
at the results he had against them
in the first part of the tournament four
draws he can't keep that up if he's
gonna become
a candidate or i should say the
candidate once more
not a chance he's got to find some
points
otherwise he can simply forget about it
and
maxim vashti lagrave he was sitting so
pretty
after the first seven rounds but two bad
rounds i should say at least one big
loss against
caruana dropped him back off the pace
and now he's got grishak and alexenko
two good matchups if you want dynamic
play
but look at round 13 against nepo once
again
can he pull it off once more the victory
that he had in round seven
we shall see that's going to be a huge
game that's coming up
in round 13. and finally the man
everybody in this tournament is jealous
of
at the moment jan nippon she he is
a point ahead of the field a big win
against his countrymen carol alexenko
has put him
in this enviable position he has caruana
today
and then his next three players look at
the results he had against them in
rounds
five six and seven a win a loss
and a win he will definitely be looking
for more goodies like that
more wins and losses of course this
mercurial player we know he plays
incredibly quickly his talent
is undisputed he's just simply a
brilliant tactician a creative player
sometimes too creative for his own good
but it looks like it's put him in a
great situation
in this event and who knows will
russia find another challenger guys
sergey karjakin did it back
in 2016. is it time once again
for nepo to possibly bring the title
home to mother russia
well let's take a look at the the full
pairings for this round 11
alejandro nepal miachi against karana
we've mentioned it and that is
a big game but as we'll see soon maybe a
bit of a dud
alexenko against wang hao definitely an
interesting game but not the most
important for
the standings alexander grisham with the
white pieces against maxine vasherla
graph despite
the black pieces of the frenchman you
know that he's going to be fighting for
some sort of sharpness
he needs to be scoring some points
speaking of that and his gear with the
white pieces he needs to find some way
to press
against the ultra solid dingleran who
hasn't really been
in top shape in this tournament but what
a dangerous player
he can be and yasser let's jump
right into the action where do we get
started today
yeah the games have been underway let's
start with our tournament leader nepo
he's white against
fabi fabi obviously trailing by a point
needs to do
something he nepo is very very happy
with the draw
it was a scotch a very topical
scotch opening and after these early
trades
they quickly got themselves into a
ending that so far all we've been seeing
throughout
is just peace is getting traded more and
more pieces getting traded more and more
visas getting traded
so much so that at the end of
as we get started the players are in a
rook ending which
to my eyes is a dead draw they'll play
it till move 40
but nothing's happening there yeah if i
may if i may while you do that
this is the kind of position a lot of
amateurs might say what draw what what
are you talking about
uh it looks like he's got an extra pass
pawn but
you would assess that this past pawn is
not going anywhere
yeah it's three versus two so it's an
equal pawn structure but this pawn
is basically blocked as soon as the rook
goes to b7 well you can't actually do
that because then after a trade of rooks
whoops the black rook gets behind the
pass pawn forces white to put his rook
in a very ungainly spot on a7 where all
is doing is nursing the pawn
no chance that this pawn is ever going
to promote with this rook firmly behind
it
the problem as amateur players may
discover for themselves um you just
can't push the pawn through
if you did something uh nice like
something like this with the idea of
bringing your rook to the seventh there
goes the pawn
so in short it's just simply impossible
for
for uh white to make headway now on the
other side
if you're fabby fans and saying well
does fabi have any chances
uh fabi will have to push his pawns all
the way up to the king's side
create some kind of a mating threat and
then
you know no all you're going to end up
is getting perpetual check at best
so i'm sorry to say to all the fans draw
in the offing there
let's just jump to the game between
carol and wang hao
uh interesting idea of
uh wang hao out of the opening he
started a flank attack
on the king side early flank attack with
h6g5
we all saw uh vladimir kramnik beat
levon aronian and berlin and that became
such a very popular way
of play for black but this position i
see it as basically pretty darn balanced
those weaknesses on the
king side you bet but there's also a big
weakness on d3
let's jump to two much more exciting
games these are the
games of the round uh alexander grishik
has sacrificed a pawn
against mvl for these kinds of um
i want to say dragon style attacks you
know what i'm talking about maurice you
love this stuff
h4h5 sax sack mate as bobby fisher would
say
i don't know if it's a sax mate but a
very exciting game going on between
grishok and mvl and finally jumping
to another game a resurgent anish geary
up with the white pieces against
uh ding lyrin and in a position where
both players have kings on opposite
flanks
we love those types of middle games
double-edged middle games
black is going to try to open up the
king side white is going to pry open
the queen side he's just played has
anish
the move bishop e3 trying to force
c5ab check out that response yes
i don't know i don't care that you're
attacking my pawn on c5
wow just like what a great move what's
the point if you take on f5 i think you
go
c4 f5 c4
and e4 or e4 right away uh
i think you start with c4 because that
hits the knight or
on b3 right if you take on c4 i'll go e4
and that's a nasty pin
because you take on f3 with a tempo so
you're gonna lose the knight
whoops don't want to do that don't have
time for g4
but alejandro let's see
what would happen you did get to play c4
but
okay i'm rolling with oh is there some
some nasty no spider sense is tingling i
don't yeah i don't know
i don't see it at the moment either
so i take on i know but i take on d3 i
take you'd have to take on d3 and i take
on f3 it's that simple
and how do you take the very
the very desirable knight f3 walks into
e4
nice point i think it's that simple
yeah because i have with the pawns
strategically this is terrible
yeah that those are nice pawn sacrifices
for black i play this
all day with the black side no not happy
about that
but the other move i is i'm a pawn
grabber in the family here
only room for one let me take it like
this
uh obviously you don't want me to take
and play g4 so i'm assuming
after bishop c5 knight i don't think
you'd take that right i think you go
queen f7
oh thank you of course you do you go
queen f7
that's a nasty tempo against my knight
ah
and if i am forced to retreat in this
way you can force me to have
some ugly double pawns oh how ugly is
that but
ugly yeah it is a pawn right it is you
also open up the b
file as well to b7 access so
that wouldn't be anything to write home
about maybe you have to go crazy go like
g5 or something
and not not to take on c5 but to go g5
yeah now that's going crazy
i could do crazy wait a minute take on
your take now and you you have to be
very mindful about what's happening next
if you're
if you're black you could sacrifice a
piece in this line i was gonna play g4
but maybe it's a bit much
is it g4 here no that's fun
this kind of crazy sign me up for this
is this is a commentator's dream
oh double edged position i mean wow
uh i'm really uh
i i would i would have a lot of fun if
the players were to enter
these crazy i love how you're saying how
you would have fun i
what is happening but i i have to say
this
if i'm a niche geary in this situation
ding loren going all out there's there
are two possibilities one is
the the real ding lorraine will the real
thing lauren please stand up
if he shows up and plays this kind of
brilliant chess and knocks you out
well too bad but if you're on each geary
looking for
a game where you might get chances to
win this is it
you've got to show yourself are you
ready to defeat magnus carlsen or
challenge magnus carson at least
you've got to show yourself when
somebody dares to play this kind of
chess against you
that you can not only defend the
position but that you can win the
position
so this kind of imbalance position
after that quiet opening guys this is
all you could dream of if you have white
you might lose the game it's a three
result game i
you might lose the game but if you're if
you're if you play
for the win if you want to win what more
do you want in a position where
it's not clear would you bet the house
that black's gonna win this game just
because the movement five is on the
board
it's not a clear position so therefore
it's anybody's chances
you've got to show yourself if you're
going to become the challenge
absolutely it's a great test for anish
giri because like you said
it's all about becoming the challenger
and
let's face it if you want to play the
top dog number one in the world you got
to get past
player number three and player number
two well player number three
ding there in on the other side
not anymore play bishop takes on c5
not anymore guys remember dingleran no
longer the number three player in the
world
why is that because john nepomney
actually passed him last round
ah thanks to the winner so
a lot of good good things have happened
to uh nepo
overnight look at this bishop takes c5
by the way on the board and you know
this is just i have experienced this so
many times you play in these
really strong double round robin events
and it's like somebody you know it's the
definition of the tournament somebody's
got to be last
so there's ding lauren you know
wallowing away in the basement
and you're just hoping that you know he
doesn't do anything crazy
special and you know he could play
spoiler roles who anish geary
really easy in this type of position
bishop's already done in this tournament
right he started with two losses
did dingle ren and then fabi went all
out with a prepared novelty sacrificed
two pawns in the slav
and dingler and just refuted it over the
board
near perfect game i mean i don't like to
say that
we're human beings we don't play
perfectly but i gotta tell you that was
a real tip of the hat to dingler in to
withstand a double pawn sacrifice i
remember and he just
he just neutralized the initiative and
he played
perfect it was nice bishop c5 is on the
board
i know the capture has been played this
he's down a pawn now
talk about sacrificing pawns he's the
one who's down upon now and
giri basically with this move is saying
thanks for the pawn
and maybe i'll pull off what you pulled
off against fabi i
took got it now show me what you've got
pocket
yeah queen f7 is certainly playable but
as you pointed out they're defensive
resources
for white yeah well this is the most
natural move
uh i i thought knight takes c5 was
actually a natural move too but then
after knight takes e5
you know what are you going to do is
you're just going to play a positional
pawn sacrifice
with f4 and you know you you know what
it's all
about queen f7 has been played right i
think you leave this bishop alone
because it's not doing much to you right
now you don't know if the knight might
take it on a better at a better timing
right
exactly yeah i like the move queen f7
uh tempoing the night by the way i'd
just like to get
your quick judgment on this position
because
i have played um
geez i played e4 e5 i'm white and i go
bishop i've played the joko piano as
white
and a max lang attack where i sacrificed
upon
in order to get this kind of pin
on my opponent and then played for a
king side attack
i used to love that
as white in other words this is right
out of my
school schoolboy textbook here
i like black but what do you guys think
it's a pawn
but uh you're not playing d4 anytime
soon and g5 g4
is really fast just a quick judgment who
would you prefer black or white in this
position
i think normally i would prefer black
but there's the move queen a2 bothers me
queen a2 yeah just saying go ahead
ding my king side and yeah uh
i like black all day it's yeah but if
you get king h2 rook g1
this would be great i mean if i get it
right
but if i don't get it doesn't work
so fast
rook h1 and now it's time to run the
other
but that's the thing right if i get to
e2 i'm basically winning
winning is strong but i understand the
point okay you're saying that uh
you some fancy defensive resources and
and you're happy but yeah the initiative
does lie with black
in that pawn sacrifice dinglerin said
hey listen
that may be whatever whatever i'm not
interested i play queen f7
uh ball's back in onisha's court maurice
what uh what did we come up with last
time
we played knight back to d2 which makes
perfect sense
yeah you're also holding f3 with this
yeah starting f3 so there are no
ideas on that score ever ever
however again the c pawn
that he took and it's a long term
sacrifice to be sure black doesn't quite
feel it
in this moment and black is thinking
aggression aggression aggression
i don't see exactly how it plays itself
out but white doesn't seem to have
any real future in this position in
terms of what's the plan
and i like your f4 move by the way
wondering what that bishop is doing on
c5
as uh you know there's this i don't feel
the pawn loss
if if i had black in this was if you
just dropped me in a position and said
don't count pawns just what do you think
like
man black looks nice that pin g5 is
coming eventually
what's not to like about black's game
this looks like taylormade
for an attack by the way speaking of
taylormade for an attack
we've got to look at the other game the
two of these contenders might be going
down as grishchuck has shown up
with uh some bombs he's deciding to drop
today
against maxime what a sacrifice we saw
earlier with h5
don't forget that h5 move to open up the
file was played
and now we see g4 allowing knight takes
f4 by the way
he did not take on f4 instead allow this
jeep on to rambunctiously run down the
board
we've got to analyze this line obviously
knight takes on f4 was a playable move
but it would have opened up
the h file tremendously and
we're seeing in this i'm just noticed he
made a move
that the engines hate i'm i'm seeing
some kind of
bar go nuts uh in this position
knight back to h5 you just made two
moves and put a knight back on h5
allowing
f5 potential f6 maxim might be getting
pasted in this game
i mean f5 f6 looks really
sad you need to do something about that
uh
normally speaking when i think about the
types of attacks
that white players do get against the
dragon uh normally that f pawn hasn't
played such a
a huge role uh playing f3
f5 uh guys this feels
like it could just be strategically lost
well strategically
tactically practically you're attacking
you're lucky if you walk out here
out of here with your teeth still in
your mouth this is um
awful looking uh
you mentioned a moment ago knight takes
f4
uh i agree you know the h file is open
is it why did maxine
[Music]
probably he was just frightened to death
of rook
h7 and i mean look at that bishop
usually the dark square bishop for for
white is not
fee and shadowed maybe he just thought
this was gone
i'd be scared i'd be terrified i'm also
scared with the pawn being on f5 though
and this might be the lesser evil
okay after night back uh
i was thinking i'm sorry oh sorry can we
you say
i just want to continue this line with a
little bit of a crazy punch
takes takes takes rook h7
immediately completely believe you i
don't believe me either but i just want
to see it
keep going and now
my little knight d5 i want to play no
knight d5 immediately right
if you go rook e8 yeah because that
threat is
right on i don't see the checkmate after
bishop takes b2 but
well there is a queen hanging i mean
i don't have a choice because knight d5
gets made it
well immediately oh you mean i should
have played f6
i think so yes gotcha i agree
and uh let's go queen eight seven arcade
six
and is there a real threat no it is
queen g1
queen g4 yeah queen g1 queen g4 covers
everything nasty
that's the end of that product okay that
refutes that and
and there was no way to get anything
else
no all right but but the point is that
marie says that h-bond is tender it's
going nowhere
uh queen h2 you need the battery anyway
bam
the defense looks difficult right
really difficult i i think maxine may
probably made a good choice f6
well hold on with your h-pawn with your
h-pawn leading
i mean with your with your rook leading
and not your queen after queen h2 would
you be five
that's brave and rookie rook c3 and
no no no no
rook c3 no no no
no no no you're not me are you meeting
me somewhere
yes and no jam for you
what do you mean i'm running right so
you're not running anywhere
queen h6
i mean rook aj next i
can't figure out how to queen d4 at the
end
oops sorry no go rook c8 queen h6 uh
i'll play devil's advocate quick
no queen d4 i'm still gonna defend yeah
uh there's a battery all right but oh my
gosh that's crazy
all right just a second so check
and i gotta have a mate here i just
don't
i just don't believe there's anything i
agree with that one
that would be against the rules
but okay hold on in this oh jesus i was
i had a crazy idea but forget it
oh geez uh sorry it was
here what maurice no i i
miscounted because i'm only up a piece
so i was trying to win
when you're rook by sacrificing my queen
queen g1 business
yeah my idea you can you can take a look
if you want sure please i'll show the
line the same line you went through all
the way to your g5 move
rook takes c3 so that's a piece
what is this it's a it's oh so it's
pieces of two pawns at the moment right
so it's a beast and oh no it was bishop
e5 sorry i apologize bishop e5 rook h7
rook c3 so it's a piece in one pawn now
rook moves all right over rook over
rook over and then you play check in g5
i mean you probably should start with
queen d4 if you're going to go into this
variation of the rook fc8 i think
oh no but that's made on h8 that's made
on h7 never mind
exactly so
just for the audience uh what uh
aleandro was saying yeah
queen d4 looks really good you do
protect the mate but the problem is
like this is the same variation queen h7
mate but you could play king g7 in this
case right
yeah you're good you're different i
could take on uh i could play g5
yeah that seems like mate
ooh very tricky
but i'm sorry it's like wait a minute
wake up have your coffee after a move
like that one
hitting the queen and threatening mate
on b2 just point that out yes you gotta
yeah you gotta show your genius and
that's without my jesus
that's brilliant hitting the hitting the
queen protecting all the mates
hitting the rook on h8 and oops by the
way i'm threatening mate
on b2 there's a lot of calculation you
can make here but i think that
black uh black
hold on i can take but if you take the
queen
and then take on e5 with check
and then take the rook and we get this
position
black is still in a box
uh rooks will leave the board but that
but a brook
the rooks leave the board in this line
but the rook oh the pawn on f4
check and check and take this piece
and now you can check and test the king
if you want to where will the king go if
you go to c7
let's make this point if you go to d7 is
perfect but if you go to c7
then rook f8 and you're behind this pawn
getting that
and the f pawn doesn't run but king d7
brings a completely different
argument because now you could go after
the b-pawn but you got to worry about
that f-pawn
what is this end game guys king c1
i think for a lot of dragon players that
kind of happy
it's weird i think we've probably gone
way off the
tracks here let me just uh refresh the
the position for a moment bristol hasn't
moved so we can we can sit on this
and languish as long as we want hold on
uh what's the current
game position the same position it
hasn't changed yeah this is the position
and grishok has not played the move that
f5 are you surprised
yeah that's grishard after all it's
christian i mean
we've seen him not make captures that
were forced that is true
that was true like f5
committal with with possibilities i
remember
the sink fill cup i they just made time
control
and he had the most obvious recapture
that we've ever had to do commentary for
and he sat i don't know for like 30
minutes
before he played the the most obvious
movement it was like
dude were you calculating but here f5
begs to be played alternatives
h5 yeah there's alternatives but
f5 looks so convincing completely
impractical
to play like this when you have such
simple moves to play this one
also uh the only thing i don't like is
like this queen might
just intrude and but at five anyway
right
i mean f5 is yeah you're just going to
play it so it seems it's the right thing
to know but
i like this less actually rook dh1 queen
f2 seems kind of annoying
well i don't yeah uh
i can't kick the queen out of
dodge right there's no it kind of sticks
around which is annoying yeah
exactly exactly you want to just a clean
attack
um no i i agree and for those reasons
i'm thinking
f5 f6 bury the bishop here
sacrificed the exchange and again to
quote bobby fischer
uh me uh f5
f6 not not what i want but
oh my god i'm i'm looking for it it's so
bad really
i mean even knight d5 is such an awkward
move to
deal with fake with the queen and oh
stop
i can sack on h5 now yeah h5 is not even
a sakura just wins
just play g6 on the next yeah g6 next
one stop
horse is dead yeah this is really yeah
this is
now this well wait a minute c2 might be
i think i start with fg6 right and then
double it and he can
gotcha okay now you're talking
that that's chocolate yeah yeah
munch rook takes h5
stop please no no that's very not okay
so
i be i don't understand it after f5 uh
i don't even see a defense well maybe
you just move the rook because i mean
the bishop on h8 is just going to let
me to be made it right i'm going to get
made it down the h file at some point if
i put the bishop on h8 so let's put it
on f8
hope for the best seriously close your
eyes to the king side because it's not
going to be pretty
no but okay uh yum
i mean nobody nobody likes defending
but no this just says
this has there's nothing appealing about
black's position here
i mean you're supposed to enjoy yourself
when you're playing chess and
if you're black there's no pleasure here
there's no there's no
there's just no counter play anywhere
there's no threat you can make
maybe you literally play like no threat
five or something dumb like this but
even this with this outstanding knight
coming to one of these two squares now i
just
well maybe by the way did rook c2 work
as fabi has drawn against janna
pomnyachi we expected that result for
sure
now you take them c2 maybe
and say that this end game is not so bad
for me because you
at least in this case have a passer
that's a good
that's a good-looking passer h4
well it's not that good-looking http3
maybe it is hg3 king e2 bishop c5
but i even this is lost king can you
take money
even this is losing amazing
you know it's bad but even your
great your the desperados are losing
uh by the way sorry uh to boldly state
the obvious we
did see a draw in the game between nepo
how far did they play it because
f5 was played by the way f5 is on the
board and that's big f5 is a big move
but yeah they went
they went they went far enough control
the titan they got to move forward
as as is regulated i i just want to say
i love these sofia rules i've always
loved them i thought that
encouraging or forcing the players to
play to the first time control
that's a very reasonable thing no draw
offers between
mu 40 guys i mean it is the world but do
you like it
yes sir when i organize the millionaire
chess open
i've all you know always been anti-draw
but when i
uh off when i offered this idea the
millionaires open when i organized that
event
i got so much pushback
what do you mean you're gonna force them
to play chess
yeah no way man the professionals should
be able to do whatever they
like how can you tell them that they ca
they can't just play a sleepy draw after
12 moves
and walk out of there that's not your
business now of course
it's standard operating procedure in
many events you
can't offer a draw early it's
disrespectful to the fans
and the modern day fighters look at it
like so what big deal we can we can
handle ourselves we're big boys
and girls uh we we can get this done so
yeah yes i'm 100
for this and it just and it's shown time
and time again that it does
not diminish the quality of play if
anything
it improves it and improves the fighting
chances and helps with
the spectators and the sponsors we're
putting up real money
this is too many benefits for us to be
complaining about whether or not the
professionals
should have rights well
well and alejandra i wanted to ask you
the same and also from the university
collegiate perspective of
if that rule exists in in those
competitions
actually most of collegiate chess
nowadays is rapid anyway
so most of those games are fighting
chess as it is and nobody's counting
moves
so we don't have a move counter uh
nobody's
recording their games so we just let
them play and they're collegiate players
they're
out for blood all the time anyway so we
don't really
need it at that point rapid chess
usually you can see that
fights happen organically whereas in
classical chess you see a lot more
let's say quick draws maybe resting
draws but
such things just doesn't happen at the
collegiate level uh let's take a look at
some of what's happened in this
dinglerang game i'm actually kind of
enthused about it because what a crazy
way to handle
the spanish right you never guessed it
such a sharp position
came from a deferred exchange spanish
such a quiet variation
but what's going on i'm eyeing this
weaknesses on the king side i'm eyeing
tactics with like g
takes h3 i'm eyeing h6 what's still a
pawn to the good
but it's kind of blown up and his king
feels a bit unsafe
it has blown up and i i'm i'm having
trouble
myself uh because
the approach that ding lyrin took
was probably what i could best describe
as the most ultra aggressive approach
that a player can take
i mean i'm one of those guys who'd like
you know to
to slow play it go f4 go rook g8 go g5
and g4
and you know maintain this pin
what he did is he played g5 captures
g4 now of course if taking this could be
really bad news but uh
anish got this opportunity to play
knight to g5 so now there is no more pin
and he has played h4 which means that
the king side for the moment
is just a little bit shut down and
well there is a massive central square
for a night to one day show up
so is there a knockout because if
there's not a knockout
there's not there's no knockout then
why i mean the knockout would be
remarkable given
given conditions on the ground right now
this is uh
what about some thing like what about
like h6 g3
i gotta try something right h6
g3 looks like a pawn doesn't it like you
want a second
no you get an extra you want to get an
exchange no no no i'm not going to take
that fast i'm going to take on d3
you're right excuse me yes of course
and then i'm up some material at least
yeah no no here you are
material there's no night jump knight d6
will be captured
uh although yeah so it'll be okay
this is a very forcing variation h6 g3
okay uh how bad is it that
how about takes on g3 with the pawn
oh no but i still fork everything on d3
no
no you just fork one person but rook
moves to e1 and that geometric is
different
[Music]
now you're actually down upon and will
have to prove some kind of compensation
i can put a knight
back back where you have to go to a1
the problem with knight d2 is oh no
can you see the x x-ray
bam yeah well knight a1 funnily enough
is not that good no i don't like the
night out
but okay uh right here i just wanted to
ask
yeah have you just moved the queen right
yeah just what is this
what's my big idea you you have
opened up the g file i'll give you that
i mean but
at the moment it's not check made and
again one of the f5
yeah and this knight on e4
is it's a pretty nice night yeah all
those last several moves by the way
improved
white's pieces white got the queen to e3
the knight on e4
the last two moves h6 you take this
position
and you play h6 and g3 and look at
white's pieces
then and look at white pieces white's
pieces
now it's like thanks for those last few
moves i just simply approved everybody
and all my prospects great night double
rooks on the on the f
file and you're still down a pawn
most tellingly just to make sure yasser
knows that he doesn't
well i'm doing either way uh apologies
uh there
uh during that uh as we were coming on
the air and we were analyzing the game
of fabi i didn't count the pawns i
thought that fabi was for choice
didn't really realizing he was a pawn
down so
ugh do count the pawns let me know h4
and okay the question i had was
okay let's bring some pieces over to the
king side
and gift me the pawn on on
uh d3 as i'm also angling for
ideas of g3 how does this one
break i'm curious about the bishop to e7
well we're both on the same page yeah
bishop seven looks curious well
and now that again you're opening the f
file with this yeah here i think i can
take on
g3 if i can count this correctly take on
e2 take on f5 take on d3 take on f6
and your rook on d8 is still hanging so
i'll be up a bit of material at the end
maybe
more than a bit not really you're only
one only one pawn and i got two
pretty active looking bishops but my
knights are not bad here actually i go
knight e6
e6 oh my desire
no you've got check away no that's fine
i'm playing h2
okay i'm actually thinking white has the
initiative for a little bit because my
king is very safe on h2
the black king is in serious trouble the
other knight lines on c5
that's right we'll have to get rid of
that thing those knights are quite
beasty
yeah good point okay so it is a very
well again guys i i just wanted to say
if g5 isn't
like really really great for black
f5 f4 is a very easy move to play
instead g5 may be
just a bad idea
you know i i said this just a few moves
ago that's a great
way right i said this a few moves ago
when
what was the move number when anish
played the move bishop six
takes on c5 on move 18. when he played
bishop takes c5
that was four moves ago and i said
if you want to win this thing if you
want to win this event
you're going to have to deal with some
kind of storm somebody trying to hurt
your feelings
you got to prove yourself and but you
just took a pawn
and will the real slim shady that is in
the body of ding loren
will he stand up and show that he's got
some compensation some attacking chances
whatever but you've got to go into
the fire and prove yourself the worthy
challenger
and these last few moves has shown that
anish is saying
okay i see your aggression and i'll take
your pawn
and let's see what happens and right now
the way this is going it looks like the
variations
completely favor him yeah we still have
to find some kind of real counter play
for black because this knight coming to
e4 is extremely annoying
absolutely and again if
if i'm in ding's shoes for just a moment
when we go back to this position if i
was
ever going to play a variation with
f5 f4 i would
like my queen actually to be on e7
square on the f7 square
i'm always vulnerable to such things so
if
i mean he made his determination when he
played the move queen f7
he made the determination he wasn't
going to play for
these types of variations with f5 f4 he
wanted to do it
uh with g5 with the mcqueen f7 he
basically said yeah i'm
committing myself to this position now
maybe he has something crazy in this
position that we're just missing i mean
this bishop on
c7 you would you'd love to play a move
like e5
e4 and blow open the position but i just
i just don't see that nice take with the
queen the problem is the queen doesn't
have any good square to go to
right precisely the desired
uh idea of setting up a battery just
isn't there after queen takes e4
no timing so uh h6
94 what the
most forcing yeah it seems to be
actually favor
white no no it's great for white
actually yeah
and i'm going to say the fact that
digloren is stopped and think this is
thinking about it this long good sign is
a terrible sign especially
given the lack of confidence he's shown
at various points in this event
i'd say anish is feeling a lot more
confident as the seconds take by
we don't see a natural follow-up we're
trying natural moves
and if we're we're bereft of ideas
given that the natural lines are not
going anywhere and we're actually able
to move the pieces around
as well then it's unlikely that there's
anything
hyper dramatic that's going to unfold
that we don't see
it's not that kind of position it's not
like there's a shocking what about what
about
no no we we got we got to do something
here we got to go knight f6 i think
knight f6 is the only
realistic activity bishop e7 knight
i mean they're not my pieces who cares
95
exactly that now you've hit it this is
like
exactly what i do with larry christensen
larry and i
you give him and i a position we throw
the pieces we're down to rook in no time
and then we say to each other well look
man they're not my pieces
knight d5 let's go let's have some fun
bishops
what's a big decision like three
different decisions yeah because
i have four decisions actually i could
take with the rook i could even take
with the bishop and hit g5
i could play knight f4 and hit the queen
but i don't see that working after queen
e4
i could take on c3 which forks the queen
and the rook on b1
but still feels like it'll come out
short right
right i bet that's probably the least
but the problem is if i take if i take
on d8 with either piece
the problem is just something landing on
e4 probably a queen even just to control
some squares
[Music]
again i would love to have a good square
for this black queen right
right
and down upon at the moment so not an
exchange too that's probably
an exchange and an exchange as well so
yes i mean this
you're not coming back easily from this
one no no
no i don't see enough counter play by
the way guys while he's
pondering that and grit and giri's
chances yes
are growing geary fans are becoming a
bit bit more confident of possibilities
let's
take a look at the other wildfire game
absolutely and i'm going to say
something strange
and i know you're going to you guys are
going to boo me out of here
get the heck what are you talking about
as an attacking player
of course i love white's position but
if you can't find anything very concrete
it's one of those how many ways can i
crush this guy
this this this or this if you can't find
anything concrete and you're
staring at this position i might not
mind
and i even as i'm saying it i want to
punch myself in the face
i might not mind being maxime in this
position
you say that with a straight face
i know i know i know but
you know who you're playing and it's
grisha
and it's i know he he's
he can prove time pressure like the best
of him he may be the best
bad time situation player in the world
but you do you would have rather had
something else granted but it is a sharp
crazy position
maybe he'll go down some wild path that
gives you some chances
maybe i say that again maybe
let me answer you very clearly i once
made such a beautiful eloquent speech
uh to a player bent larson
uh during a postmortem he looked at me
and he said nobody believes you
it's worse when you don't believe
yourself
you know we we've got we're chess
players
we have to falsify our own hypothesis
we've got to have an
open mind as much as we can so try to
have an open mind
in this position and as soon as i said
that my phone just fell
and it's like i'll make him break out
in his face like nobody's listening to
you maurice but
let's let's take a look what are you
going to do to kill the guy
that's f6 this is grishik's answer to
you maurice f6
bishop f8 we were looking at rook h5
guys
did he play f6 yet by the way yes he did
yes absolutely finally
the bishop is forced well this about it
just
i want to say well the real maurice
ashley just said the master of the
attack
is sitting there saying well there's
good defensiveness
the guy's going to get in time trouble
there's no immediate
knockout blow marie by the way we've
been looking at
rook h5 which i think is really strong i
just want to be a hundred percent sure
that
even no that that this is asking too
much
no why isn't this asking too much
extra the thing is the problem so far in
my opinion hasn't been
so much that you're getting clobbered on
the king side which you kind of are
but you can imagine that maybe in some
miracle situations there will be some
defense
but where's black's counter play if i
just exchange your knight on h5 right
knight g3 i actually like knight g3
d5 or a bust i'm going to say there's
only one break
and it's d5 are bust as far as i'm
concerned you've got to
but you know h5 h5 no but don't take it
here's the thing
where is black's play after i take on h6
maybe i don't penetrate
no no i'll take on h6 why am i giving
you a free pass pawn on the king side
take on h6
yeah and uh whoa whoa whoa
it's d5 or bust i need to play d5
i need to put i cannot just sit here
it's got to be d5
every variation every line you're gonna
have to calculate this move
just here i'll throw in h7 of course
why not never and i don't i don't
believe in this at all
for black knight takes e5 take that pawn
on h7
all right now c2 isn't c2 hanging
yeah i have the second exchange to pull
it off now but rook state 2 queen c2
should just lose right unless you have
rook takes d5
i was going to start with d5 i wasn't
even i was thinking about d5 just to
start
ah rook d5 immediately okay looking past
pawns coming at me all right uh my
bishop
is acting like it's guarding the whole
[ __ ]
kind of funny i wouldn't be surprised if
oh but at least i have at least have
queen c2 queen f2 check
well i have 21 here i mean i'm not going
to give up my material i'm pretty greedy
as a chess player
i don't actually see a threat
who needs a threat i just wanna survive
okay what's this e5 is okay i i can't
take on b2 how do i get
at you i need the f5 square or the e4
squared
neither one of which looks available no
no you're
white as a material black
has no clue how to get in the game and
knight g3 played by the way guys
yeah uh he heard you for sure
i think the line that i was trying to i
was trying to get a line like this
actually this was uh this looks over
yeah
yeah this was like the i mean the
combination of these two pawns
it's just just not it's overkill so
that's why we do have to play knight g3
now i was playing h5 for the simple
reason like
you know if i if these rooks ever land
on the eight
excuse me these rooks ever land on the h
file
when you play h5 he may just play rook
h5 uh the build
up so i played h5 but maurice is
basically saying
uh black with this passive
king side needs to put his eggs in the
d5
basket and just hope for the best is
black up a pawn
yes currently yes he's trying to make
sure takes h5 i'm giving away everybody
when
yeah when you do this h5 will come later
i'm hoping h5 comes at a time when you
have to
when when you can't stack understood so
d5
understood okay we've been looking at
knight d5 and
more or less we continued with
uh rook takes d5 uh had we just traded
nights
this is like abysmal i mean this is just
horrible
yeah strategically everything about this
position
just feels terrible and and maxine will
know
uh this absolutely a moment ago by the
way when i
i played the move uh h5
my intention and i never got to really
play it was to play king h7
in the words of walter brown immediately
here i go 95
this is also horrible and are you going
to take with the pawn
no with the queen with the queen and so
uh because the bishop even though it's
really
really cramped it is alive okay but i'll
take
e5 and i think you'll cry
if you take e5 you know i'm going to cry
that was not
uh my
that's i mean rook c3 something whatever
right i think it's just
completely lost well because of this guy
yeah
yeah you can take and
i can take i can go bishop d4 first i
can well
you can no no bishop d4 before taking on
[Music]
yes very nice very nice by the way uh
birdie whispered in my ear that dingler
in has been on a 20-minute thing
nah good for our niche fans not the
greatest follow-up to g5
no ultra zealous four moves after
allowing bishop
take c5 he is deep in the tank wondering
what did he do
where is the compensation uh that
position does
not look good for him uh at all
as as now and he you know he doesn't
want to just be desperate
that's the precise kind of thing where
anish will say keep going along these
random fishy lines so i can refute what
you're doing
anish is the perfect person for that if
anish doesn't believe you
like completely doesn't believe you he's
super confident
and a great defender indeed so aneesh as
far as i'm concerned
has a draw in the pocket like no
surprise
he's not going to just lose this game to
some rolling attack some great
compensation that black
is proving for this extra pawn he's got
a draw in the pocket right now
and he's starting to think draw what
draw i might be able to win this one
up a pawn up on time 20 minutes left not
severe but with a lot of moves to go 18
moves and you're the one who's down the
pawn and trying to prove something
this is uh there's some really good
trending right now
for the dutch player absolutely by the
way
for ding there in this this is again one
of those kind of
bad misfires that he's been doing in the
tournament
at certain moments in this event dingler
in has played
brilliant chess i mean the type of chess
that propelled him to being the number
three player in the world but other
times it's like
you know it's been backfiring and
this looks like a pretty clear case of
the latter backfiring
i don't see a decent
move at the moment we've been looking at
knight f6 but we keep coming
up empty-handed
you know it's really surprising it it we
said
ding loren is a great player from china
he's been over 2800 he's slipping back
now
he's shown himself to be an incredible
chess genius
but i was thinking last year that he had
a bad result in the first half of the
twenty
definitely a bad result but you could
come back the next year and say but it's
a whole year later why should i
even be thinking about having a bad
result when i was off form
then it looks like you can put the two
tournaments
side by side as though it's a simple
natural continuation
of last year as though they were as
though
he had picked it up the very next day a
year passed somehow
nothing happened and he's still the same
player playing with uncertainty
not playing as accurately that when he
had that big
position against against maxime that he
didn't win
that seems like he was in the middle of
the slump from last year
but it was a year later it's so
interesting that the psychology should
remain for the event
as though he's kept the burden and the
emotional
uh i guess it is the emotional burden
from
last year and and it's carried over
into this event i've got no chance why
should i
care i'm going to continue to play
without any motivation
real motivation if i win i win so
what you know if you see the press
conferences
of dingle around in this tournament
that's basically the attitude you get
from him right i have too few points
what does it really matter i'm going to
show up and i'm going to play some chats
but let's face it
i'm on -2 to start the event there's no
real chance
and it's a tough tournament but it's not
the same approach that
everybody else would take right fabi
gets a year of prep says oh
i'm going to get mvl round one if i win
that one i'm back in the mix
anish is the same thing he wins one game
he's back in the mix grizz took the same
thing
one win back in the mix of course he
lost so he was relegated but you go into
that tournament with that
understanding alexenko he was the lowest
rated player so he says well let me make
the most of my chances
the dingleran almost 2800 only one
result to play it for which is first is
impossible
it's hard to get into that mindset of
let's try our very hardest and
let's go plus seven and win this
tournament i mean he's a very practical
chess player and i think he's a very
realistic guy
and his press conference has kind of
shown he didn't really come here to
score plus seven well yeah never mind
plus seven i just winning a game where
he was plus seven on the board against
mdl would have been
at least
so little uh depressive uh
reactions there by uh dingler in in any
case
20 minutes and counting guys i think
it's even closer to 25 as we've been
speaking dingler has not moved
and uh really a very very bad sign for
him but
i mean anish must with each minute
passing
be feeling like man this is great
stock is rising
wow just to mention the obvious uh
if he were to win this game and thanks
to fabby having me to draw he'd jump
to only a half a point behind
our tournament leader nepo and defeating
ding lorraine okay ding's not playing
well but
still psychologically you feel like it's
ding lorraine it's not
kiril alexenko no disrespect to the
young russian
but we're talking about beating one of
the top five players on the planet now
number four
after nepo's win yesterday nepo is now
the number three player
in the world i anish would be trending
really high in four rounds at that too
four rounds
plus two you we'd be saying anish is the
one playing the best chess
in the tournament that's what we'd be
saying right still only a clear
advantage it's just
a pawn we've seen worse things yeah
candidates that's not stellar like
david is losing or anything his position
looks bad i don't like his time usage
but it's still a bit of a mess and i'm
sure that he'll try to create some
chances different than what i see in
maxim's game the more i see that game
the more i analyze that game
the uglier it gets b6 played finally by
dingler and after a very long thing
a move we didn't even consider that's
gonna
that's gonna blow up some things because
i don't think you can go bishop e3
but this one this one really does look
bad
b6 v6 he played
i guess the idea is that if you go
bishop e3 knight f6 is now playable
or maybe or maybe h6 and g3 and you
don't have queen
e3 although you have queen pretty much
anywhere else
v6 by the way when we make faces like
i've just done it's because we were
trained on these steinnitzian ideas the
first world champion wilhelm steinitz
uh really rebuked
players who uh voluntarily weakened
their king's position
the move b6 means you never get to take
the move back and you've
purposefully weakened a6
yeah not even sure yeah i'm not even
sure
how how big a threat taking on b
right c5 might be and yeah d4
in which case even knight e4 might be a
response
to your move to the move right even well
i'm not saying that's what you should do
but
even that might show up in your brain as
uh that b-file looks kind of curious
but let's start with d4 the most direct
most direct
attempt at a reputation i'm probably
wondering i mean unless you gotta
reply to that i i don't see what you do
up to 95.
no that's curtains right that looks like
wow
do you just you just walked right into
uh
queen a6 is kind of a crushing sacrifice
not much of a sacrifice i must say so
what really happens that after d4
you're not going to play b5 maybe just
go knight
no i don't even want to say the knight
b8 you say your bishop's trapped
my bishop is trapped i was giving up
that bishop anyway
it's okay i'll take it i mean i'm
messing
black's got to have something here right
it doesn't have material
yeah yeah yeah exactly i mean he's
looking to
mix it up and 98 and seriously i'm with
you 100
alejandra i know what you mean
alternatives lose
so i i almost want to play knight a5
anyway just take something right
yeah but i don't like sacrificing the
knight
you don't like sacrificing the knight i
like the knight as an attacker
whereas the bishop i didn't think was as
strong of an attacking
piece
but 95 i'll take one a5 and i'm not
really sure
if i should be that worried i'm worried
don't get me wrong but am i that worried
i mean my next move is obvious
so right the problem is rook b
rook b8 your obvious uh killer
blow you can't follow it up with rook b1
i wasn't planning to i was just planning
to take on a6
go ahead take that check
and queen a6 and queen a6 yeah this
looks bad i think i have to run i think
i think with the bishop
okay queen a6 not that i was in love
with the movie takes d4 it did seem like
i understand that tempo but i do want to
see this
threat yes we got to see what's the idea
queen a6 king d7
and i'm still not really sure where the
killing blow is quick bishop c7
uh queen e5 is a tempo i think if i
would have been a nice tempo
uh-huh queen e5 it looks like a very
good tempo
oh oh geez i hate that i i hit the wrong
key
yeah okay all right so king d7
king d7 on let's let's stay right here
what about rook d1
we got a bishop hanging right
so that was why i was trying to get the
bishop
okay take a pawn whoa whoa anisha said
this bishop what bishop 94 on the board
we didn't consider that move
yes we did we did consider that if d4
wasn't an alternative do you really have
to
and there it is on the board by the way
that
puts pay to the idea of h6 and g3 right
i mean she was ready to play great great
idea
whether it was encouraged or not
and that knight was landing on e4 i
assume he's saying pretty much what
you've been saying alejandro
not impressed by the bishop go ahead and
take the bishop if you want
and i will i will just recapture
i'm not actually sure if you recapture
honestly i think you might start with d4
sure d4 all day i mean this is the move
we wanted to play
the only issue would be if i can play c4
but i don't think you can take on e4
after that for example i'm looking at
the line c4 queen takes c4
queen takes e4 the queen takes a6 king
b8 and i think knight c5 is just deadly
i don't see the defense there's no thing
looks uh
it looks terrible uh knight takes c5 b
takes e5 that rook covering the b7 that
looks like
curtains so this looks
delish maurice of course
no we've said if if not d4
the 94 was even worthy of thought
because we weren't sure that bc5 was
actually a threat
and so you could improve your position
and this move knight e4 played quickly
it's a whole piece and i don't think he
anticipated b6 by the way i don't think
anish thought b6 was a move
no doubt looking around wondering what's
going on and then when he saw b6 he said
what and and look at this a capture has
occurred
on c5 it is white board and witnesses
are
in on we
so so so hold on did you guy i like bc5
uh uh alejandro you were trying to kill
me with d4 and i
errored with some bad move i played c4
and got killed
it's not necessarily a bad move right it
does have the advantage that if i give
up the pawn and then play knight b8 i
can keep the b
file closed and i'm winning a tempo
against the e4 knight
which is then undefended so there is a
lot to be said to take on c5 first and
reserve the move d4 for later
that way i guarantee to open the b file
so
honestly i like pc5 a little bit more
intuitively
warming up to it yeah yeah okay the
question is what
what here right what now i i'm
i'm getting ready to put on my walking
shoes
i i'm going to exit uh
with king d7 by the way from ding's
point of view
he was material down a moment ago with
some
maybe nebulous compensation now he's in
the thick of it
but he is at least something in his
pocket
that he can play for material oh man
could we could analyze this i could do
me a favor and go back to this
d4 move uh sorry d4
defense and we said c4
i wasn't sure i wanted to even take that
pawn i wanted your knight more than
anything
else because that knight is in the way
but maybe
well what are you going to do here i was
probably just going to play knight b8
it's not that
i i just don't want to see a queen
landing on a6 i don't know and bc5
played quickly by
anish so he agrees with our instincts i
don't know if our analysis but b
takes d5 already played d4 coming up
next move
knight a5 i think is also a threat in
this position
so guys this one is building but
the other one is exploding uh maxime did
play
d5 after nigeria three
three and instant capture by grishchuk
and as we said one of the best bad
time situation players in the world is
chris chook but maybe he it wouldn't
even matter how much time you had on the
clock you'd say
just give me your pawn show me what you
think you have because
i am doing all this for no material
whatsoever
right now it's even material and black
position
uh in the words of professional analysis
still sucks
it still sucks i mean what are you doing
i mean
what a time to play d5 when this night
tension still exists i mean
my first instinct is like what are you
doing i can take on on
on g on h5
and completely destroy your king side
pawn structure
i think it's d4 not d e4
you think after knight takes h5 it's d4
why i think
in the words of ben larson
[Laughter]
i gotta believe it's mate over there but
okay d4
is it's it's the only idea that
everything
for queenie one breathing everything is
that's about to make it i was thinking
but you gotta make it but i like what
you were saying too maurice i mean hey
look man i'm not even material down and
i got all the pluses i had
last turn as well let me take this pawn
as long as you don't
st this is the kind of position where
you start looking for wins
as white right yes this to move and win
this to move
as long but you can also look at it as i
am actually winning
i don't have to look for wins this is
just gonna play itself
i'm just gonna beat you you're you can
wriggle around
all you want to and try to be as
slippery as ever
when until i see something really
confusing like alejandro's last move d4
where you start going wait wait i'm
that's what i really mean i gotta
calculate i gotta look
no right until i see something like that
i'm playing the straightforward moves
and that's what he just did he said
straightforward i take on d5 instead of
this mess that we look we're looking at
with d4
let me just take on d5 what are you
doing exactly you're gonna start sacking
pieces like
you're just gonna fall apart of its own
weight so what happens if i take they
can go h5
this is this is the position that we got
uh some time ago and by the way the the
the times
of the players 13 minutes 27 versus 27
minutes so sasha as usual
has half the time of his opponent and
well double edged well not double edged
difficult uh position for maxime
i was trying to analyze the move queen
f6 i mean it's incredibly greedy but
this pawn on f6 is such a thorn true but
am i just loose the knight e4
wouldn't surprise anybody that that
would be the case right
yeah this is a wild exciting position
guys well he's filled we gotta take a
small commercial break and we will be
back with the action before time trouble
hits
so don't well go somewhere for a couple
of minutes but we'll be back
this games are heating up don't miss the
action nepo nyan she's still the leader
a full point ahead of fabiano caruana
we'll be right back
[Music]
go go
[Music]
that's our show now go play yours at
[Music]
reasonboat.com
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the us chess championships and
the sink sinkfield cup one of the
strongest chess tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills
and increased confidence the chess club
is highly engaged with the local
community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the u.s and world chess
halls of faith
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess
art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame is nothing you
expect
and everything you love three different
galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
professional golf returns to st louis in
2021 the ascension charity classic
presented by
emerson stars like phil mickelson ernie
else jim furyk and moore compete at
norwood hills country club
september 6 through the 12th tickets
clubhouse passes hospitality suites and
proam foursomes are on sale now
all proceeds go to north st louis county
charities visit
ascensioncharityclassic.com
or call 314-938-2828 pga tour golf is
back in the loo
the ascension charity classic
[Music]
welcome back let's not waste any time
let's go straight into the anish geary
game against dingleroon with a crucial
one for the standings if anish wins with
the white pieces he will be only half a
point away
from janna pomnyacci the current leader
and what's going on
b takes c5 we left it off at this
position dingley ran answer with the
move knight f6
challenging the knight on e4 and
instantly
geary said boom knight d6 check
he saw for 30 seconds about this move
and what
is going on guys impressive move
it looks like a great attacking uh
variation for anish after takes takes
this knight is coming to c5 this queen
could come over and
join an attack down an open b
file and it looks like dingleran is just
going down
i mean i just don't see a continuation
for it forget about d4
what about d4 as well d4 threatens to
take on e5
and four pieces so we got more this move
d4
opens up lines and threatens a i mean
threatens a6
threatens to take on e5 with the pawn or
maybe even with the queen
in fact and you're you're talking at the
moment
he's up upon is white for the piece
if he wins the piece back dinglerin
is dead i think at the grandmaster level
you don't even calculate this position
you don't spend
a second calculating you just
instinctively know this king doesn't
survive
exactly i i agree with you uh maurice
that
i guess it's just style right you played
d4 to bring the queen
i saw knight c5 myself followed by
i don't know uh just abusing that i like
your style yes
yeah i mean it does look pretty good too
all roads lead to roman this one i think
yeah
yeah this looks really really good and
for anish wow i mean after the first
half
nobody mentioned this young man but
when you think about how well he played
in vikanze you mentioned
already maurice in previous video um
broadcast that uh well he won the magnus
carlson
uh event uh the eponymous
event of magnus on the magnus carlson
tour
uh aneesh coming coming in with great
confidence in biking absolutely
and playing as you said rapidly he won a
rapid event and now he's playing
rapidly with confidence uh in this one
we've seen the move the capture was made
and
it's knight c5 it's d4 there
two choices looks like you can't go
wrong with
either one and digloran down to six
minutes dougie fresh you're on six
minutes
and you only have and you have as many
as 14 moves
to make 14 moves to make in this
position now seriously
if i had a king like that could i have
44 moves
a 44 minutes four minutes 24 minutes i
don't want
to have six minutes i matter of fact i
don't even want the stinky position
i just don't want to even look at it
look at black's pieces
black has that extra bishop on age five
but is it
in the game right you might have an
extra bishop
yeah exactly right you don't even feel
it white species are all poised
the issue is of course if you try to
calculate this one
to mate you may not be able to figure
that out
as you said alejandro i think that's the
biggest point strong player looks at
this position and says
why do i need to calculate it to mate
his king
is royally exposed horribly so
i have all the moves poised my rook on
b1 as a monster piece my knight is
getting to c5
i'm getting moves like d4 and you can't
even stop my queen's incursion
if i can't beat you or at least prove
com heavy compensation here
i don't deserve to try to win the world
championship try to challenge magnus
carlson
this is money in the bank no need to
calculate
and how right he is aneesh geary
showing some power chess two wins out of
the first four guys if he does that
wow three rounds to go nepo does not
feel comfortable at all
no i mean that one point lead just rank
in half
and uh yeah i mean what can i say
anish giri won a really powerful a game
that magnus carlsen himself said was a
very very good game against wang hao
uh to beat uh you know china is number
one
in this kind of fashion that will feel
really really good
and again it comes down to a stylistic
choice here d4
or knight c5 tell me what would guide
your
considerations alejandro you're a chess
coach i mean for the saint louis
university what do you tell your players
when they have such a position as
white i think first of all get to this
position
tell me the first thing achieve the
winning position step
two uh step two i think when you have
such a choice in your games right you
have knight c5 or d4
you try to cr you try to play or at
least calculate first the one that
creates the most threats
and i think knight c5 creates pretty
immediate threats
but less so than d4 because rook b8 i
don't think is checkmate
and if that's not actually checkmate if
you just make a random move
you take you go queen b2 king c7 queen
b7
and i don't see the checkmate here right
right so
if that's not an immediate threat i
think d4 just comes with more threats
you attack a6 and you attack e5 as
maurice mentioned it
so this allows me a little bit more
flexibility it would be what i would
focus my attention on
first um and
and that's how i would approach it uh
knight c5 i don't see an immediate
problem but i think i would be slightly
concerned about maybe knight d7
that's the move i would be worried about
does knight d7 right queen b2 doesn't
mate here
uh the king runs to e6 and there's a
long chase
but it does look like the king is
slipping out again
you could take on h8 in the in the line
uh d4
played by anish agreeing with us
basically right that there's a lot of
threats in the position let's just make
even more
see if it collapses eventually i'm
having trouble finding a move for black
that's the issue that's the issue and
you know what you know what's great
about this move too
is that is that the
the it's almost like you're cover you
have to cover so many threats
as black right but you you almost feel
helpless
like yeah i've got to deal with a6 i got
to deal with e5 i gotta deal with knight
c5 i gotta deal with potential
queen b2 there's so many even queen e5
by the way queen e5
because if you if you take then pawn
takes and suddenly you're just
down material with
every single thread you just play this
movement like every single single threat
now
accelerated in the position this was
terrible in a niche
how many moves since uh the move this
the pawn sack with f5
we're going back to that critical moment
of move 18 and say it again
when he played bishop takes c5 he said
show me
i see that you're attacking but it's not
so easy to knock out
gangster level players at this level all
right it's not so easy and then you made
just a few moves
and a few moves later was oh you're not
doing well at all and now i don't
believe you anymore
and now i'm going to kill you and it's
it hasn't even been 10 moves guys
it hasn't even been 10 moves since that
demonstrate it feels like it's been 15
moves but it hasn't even been 10 moves
since that f5 demonstration
by dingleran and it's a nightmare on the
chessboard
yeah it sure is i made him for dingler
and
i mean yeah i mean it's just been a
a bad tournament you know getting worse
and worse i mean
he came in with such high hopes to this
competition one year ago as world's
number three and playing scintillating
chess halfway point he was uh
languishing
in the last place and this
this position is just no no i mean by
the way dingler in himself is
a fantastic attacking player he knows
he's in desperate straits and four
minutes on the clock
this looks terrible let me just get a
quick gander of grishok
gracious by the way i just want to go
back to one point could you guys just
clear the cobwebs
i was just having this this moment where
i i'm on the fritz here it was
did maxine have a chance for rook c3 i
didn't
really uh the idea was that if you go
queen takes knight takes
i was going to end up you know like in a
situation where i could trade right
which is what black wants this would
have been a dream
um in any case if i go queen e1
instead of queen d2
uh sorry it took on d5 right
yes queen or actually maybe even more
precise so you don't have to hit me
anywhere queen f3
queen f3 okay
and yeah it's
it okay it doesn't feel sorry guys we've
got to get back to the other game
we've got to get back to the other games
c5 was played it's just
we like my eyes are expanding
on every move i'm getting bigger and
bigger like saucers watching this and
oh man could you imagine having a
position like this against
ding lorraine look at his king the last
pawn
the last pawn shield he had four pawns
once upon a time
guarding that king there were four of
them over there including the double
pawn on c5
there's now going to be only one and
then there was one
remaining and man knight what's wrong
with
knight takes on c5 and that rook v8
threat
is not still not mate he has taken on c5
how do you survive this queen two is
coming i don't know
i don't see him moving he has yet i just
oh he did oh he did
yeah on the board and what's the point
like how can you move any chess pieces
this is resigning this rook is frozen i
guess there's only knight d7 if you no
97 loses to more than one thing i think
like queen c4 looks
extremely deadly
uh you open the c file is just open
right i'm just going to take advantage
of that
yeah i always you're right alejandro i
mean here it's uh
the the one thing i was trying for with
knight d7 was to do something
even here no no no even here by the way
after your own heart yes doesn't if the
knight d7 doesn't even knight a6 work
i was hoping to run if you take knight
a6 to go start going king d8
oh my god run where i don't know but i'm
running
it doesn't matter it does not matter
away from the rooks
like king d8 allowing something like
rook e1
or rook b5 or rocky one and rook b5
they're not immediately killing me right
this is the best this is the best i can
hope from this place but
knight c5 is coming night scene i
understand it's amazing
you probably can skin this piece of the
way
however you want to do it right there's
no yeah i'm just trying to survive a
couple moves
i i'm a pawn grabber but that a6 pawn is
not that delish i i i i'm not saying
what i'm what i'm saying is they all
must see
yeah i agree rookie blake by
and asking the salient question what
queen b2 right to queen b2
i mean okay there's only one move that
doesn't get mated it's
knight d7 ah
pardon me because because if you go king
d8 at the very least knight b7
is i i think it's just made but
that's that's good enough for me too
yeah knight d7
okay and i've got to uh
and the prayer
light the candles uh i don't see them
made
but there must be there somewhere right
this has to be over
here it's not completely dead dead
dead no here i'm still still kicking
uh i i need something cleaner guys
well another move guys is queen c4
yeah the one alejandro uh was pining for
the queen threatens discover checks
uh whether they be knight e4 or 97
bishop is on h5 again i keep pointing to
this piece
saying i'm down i'm down a bishop
for two pawns now now that we've gotten
the
the number count out the way who cares
about your stinking bishop
your king is horrible the a6 pawn will
drop
anything lands on b7 we could double on
the b line
if we need to this is so sad
i can't i can't even watch it this is
what
and what's the continuation after rook
c6
i think you can move he has played queen
c4
on the board can't you sidestep with
your queen and threaten
all the same goodies like
it's just such an awkward position for
black you can't even defend this rook on
c6 i know uh
my first impression was uh for
uh queen a4 but remember a moment ago
when your rook was on d6 defending the
night maybe
maybe now uh bringing the queen to
the battery because the rook is hanging
out he's hanging
and it's like oh no why did i put my
rook on c6 i don't know
i think yeah you're right queen queen b8
is mate
like yeah that's just no this is over
this he could resign now
he's got 256 left on his clock this is
maybe one of the worst games i've ever
seen ding lauren play frankly just
but also kudos to anish for going into
this line after his opponent decided to
start playing sacrificial attacks and i
told you when anish is confident that
it's not
actually death he's co he comes from the
coach noise school
the petrossian school those guys are
like uh by the way we do have a result
guys
we do have a result doing lauren has
tossed in the towel
officially it's over what a smash
and we got to after the movie it was
queen c4 and
i've seen enough 11 moves after his f5
sacrifice
and he had to resign fully refuted
fully disgusted as ding lorraine but
anish now only a half a point behind
ding loren no rest i mean behind nepal
rest uh the keep the champagne
still on ice because yeah nepo is not
i guess it's the it's the vodka the the
russian
the russians are wait wait wait wait
wait we can't celebrate guys
aneesh geary has shown up and
the young man showing his skills
and wow what two marvelous victories
against the tank the chinese contingency
of by anish giri he's got
i mean this tournament is still buzzing
guys this incredible situation
by the way in the game between uh
grishok
and uh mvl uh grishok said
i don't want your stinking pawn go ahead
and you have
a protected past h pawn after the move
h5
because you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to telegraph
my moves i'm going to tell you what i'm
going to do i'm sacrificing a rook on h5
and i'm mating you on h8
wow that's
that's that's pretty straightforward
wouldn't you say
we're not hearing we're not hearing
alejandro at least i'm not
uh yeah i'm having trouble with
alejandro's uh mike as well
but yeah that's um
that's a yeah that's that's the question
to you
if you play a move like rook down i say
no i'm still threatening mate i'm still
threatening me
i guess the the question
is queen here because in this case
okay if i take take
take oops
i don't have the backup i need to play
queen h8 so
i'm guessing after queen d6
the simplest answer is king here that's
king that's good defense right there
so queen d6 even actually threaten
is it is it a threat to play rook it is
a threat to play rook d1
so can he play
king h2 a king a2 two yes
that's nasty to sidestep it but then
he's got to play rook d1 anyway
he's gonna have to give up oh excuse me
i cannot take
the e5 pawn with my bishop
because of the nasty queen 83
ah he's back hi uh aleandra
good good good not sure we're hearing
alejandro as yet as his audio gets fixed
but you're right rook d1 is the only
defense and the only defense
it's it's still that h-pawn on the board
why do i am i doing this right because
this just doesn't feel right
so let me try it again uh queen there
bishop here be one at all costs
all costs gotta trade off a pair of
rooks you got that past h pawn which he
didn't take
when h5 landed on the board he ignored
it a long time ago
and is this some sliver of a chance for
black to maybe fight hey
this is interesting because he dominates
the d file which is important
so that white stamps doesn't make queen
d6 that is indeed
this is going to be an amazing
turnaround absolutely
amazing turnaround how does max seem
survive these positions it's
unbelievable i know
the night or flares what he survived
against fabi was remarkable was what he
thought
surviving he didn't survive against
bobby he lost in the end
but the way he handled the opening but
the way he scrapped and
grounds his way to a table-based draw
true was something that we just had to
applaud i mean that was just amazing
and he survived ding lorraine and this
game this again
and this already chalked him up i mean
now that out okay one more look blacker
how about severely how about king up
rook down i'm trying to preserve my back
d2 gee i miscounted
the number of defenders look back to d2
of course
hello oh is it possible instead
i've got one i've got one yes what about
bishop c1 okay rook
d1 is the problem i almost lost the game
right you wanted to play here
yeah um alejandro if you're back with us
we've just seen this very
crucial move queen to d6
well we have an answer queen d6 answered
by krishna with king
a2 i think it was similar to your idea
maurice of sidestepping this
checks maybe rook d1 you go rook
one h2 but does that really really work
because that's what that's
d2 right yeah we've been looking at this
we don't see how this works i know it's
remarkable
what if you what if you take on h5 by
the way
okay what moment d1 h5 what is the
defense there
and i move my rook somewhere like h3
oh no h3h3 h3 you don't want to step on
the h5 square
got it right
um this is what it's all about
and mate on the h7 and h8 squares
can you stop it hmm i'm having a hard
time
then you can play queen e6 but i think
that's just lost right
those two rooks are not nearly good
enough
no i pro but okay which
me no rook h2 walks into uh
so that was one big difference maybe
rook h4
rook do you want to play maybe rook h4
no but then
maybe then rook d4 and then bishop
that doesn't help queen a3 check yes
you're right so rook h3
i think i like this move i was just
trying to find another alternative
square but rook h3
and here it is and here it is
rook h5 played gh5 let's see
what gristrok plays rook takes h5 is
also not something i was completely sure
if it works as well because queen h2
and queen e4 ideas but rook h3
is that just win maybe it just wins
takes on h5 and h3
um i'm having a real hard time coming up
with anything
but queen e6 and queen takes h3 by the
way
fantastic it's very bad very very very
bad i i'm
i'm not i'm not joyful at all no no no
um man we're seeing some amazing games
this round
oh what around i mean even the wang khao
game is not
boring but this is just the other two
games are so amazing
and important as well yeah mvl goes down
here
he's gone he's out of the tournament
completely
okay rick h3 is important
a1 what a move wait what does that do
though if i take with a bishop
well i was trying to deflect your bishop
from the a3 square to see whether or not
i could somehow
do some some stuff he's instead played
the move rook to
d4 this bishop that i was after no no he
took on h5
oh he too played with h3 he didn't play
rook h3 he played rook takes h5
instantly magazine what a monster rook
d4
oh boy what so you can take on a4
oh what queen h2 rook a4 what a resource
incredible turnaround now what a
resource stunning
rook he thought this was just going to
win he saw a straightforward
play and now brooke to
d4 this guy is so slippery it's on
oh my his idea is that if i take the
bishop
take the rook pardon me then you don't
have time to play queen h2 because
there's a mate
on the back rank but
is it you can slide away with a perpet
oh i'll slide oh please
please let me slide okay what a move
to miss that's fantastic what a move to
find
queen h2
now no because there's a
a rook a one at the end that hurts my
feelings so
yeah no show the line show the line yes
uh yeah it's actually checkmate on d1
it's mate it's going to be me
just before i can mate you
you get
and so he has to take yes then you go
queenie
six no i don't think queen d5 works by
the way because queen d5 king b1 queen
d1 bishop c1
so you have to go to e6 but you need
your rook in the game anyway you knew
your rook in the game right
because this just loses you need to play
queen e6
oh but it just works because rook d1
follows and queen b6 follows so what's
winning six king
b1 only move rook d1 and one bishop c1
bishop c1 queen b6
king a2 and it's just a draw right and
it's done yeah
you can't get out of here what a save
rookie are you kidding me and for sasha
grisha
he must be thinking kicking himself oh
my totally kicking himself he sacrificed
he lined up the sacrifice on h5
so that he could take on h5 not to play
suddenly rook h3
he's he's sad he's sacrificing because
i'm going to keep going
and now this movie overlooked a one
square that needed covering
the king on a2 the yes you got out of
the check on d1 but you you
allowed to check on a4 who knew that was
possible
with bringing the rook to d4 that's
amazing
what a movie i want to move rook d4 can
i
suggest rook h1 with the idea that
after rook d1 uh
now i've just simply eliminated this
pawn i don't understand rook
h1 when the rook is on d4 this position
so this position i'm suggesting rook h1
first what you're
saying right rook a4 check but rookie
for he wants to go king b1
and i wanted to go king b1 and now that
your rook is on a4
not bothering me down here here
although i don't know if i want to but i
could play rook h4
and like worst case scenario
[Laughter]
for a worst-case scenario it's probably
as in now yeah yeah
it's actually not so bad because g5
hangs at the end
oh oh sasha
and you know one of the most difficult
minutes is to to reorient yourself when
your opponent has played the superstar
move like rook d4
and you were just ready to reach out
your hand and accept your
opponent's resignation now he's got to
reorient himself and he's down to 40
seconds
with nine moves to go oh oh
my i think he might just take this eight
but
he's uh he's disgusted he can't believe
the
owl has more lives than a cat i mean
that's just unreal
what a resourceful guy uh rook h1 played
guys
rook h1 played yeah we expect
rook a4 rook h4 right i didn't see
another
remarkable i didn't see rook h4 i was
really happy that i had lured your rook
away from the d
file so that i could play queen h5 or
queen h2
but this and by the way after rook takes
a4 i
don't capture the rook because that
geometry
that's hurtful so that was why i was
going to play king b1
and then alejandro how do
how do you see him like you rook on e4
it goes flying across the board
completely to the other side necessity
absolute necessity there's no other way
to defend the age file so i
you find it easy amazing and
there's nothing i can do and you were
about to say that in the end
the g pawn would be hanging i'm assuming
you're talking about
something of this nature right like how
do i evaluate the sun game when i go
king like rogue g1
it's probably i mean this pawn is
powerful it's
annoying but but is it enough feels
closer to a draw i mean probably i'd
rather be white but wait a minute i mean
man for for mvl
he was so he was so
dead i mean like wow
it's just amazing happy scrappy player
does he have any alternatives because we
threw in rook h4 kind of
fast but i didn't know if there were
other defenses by that point
there might not be yeah i don't see him
i mean i i just like
this threat has got my attention
well i mean the the queen the queen
versus the two rook
end game is very different with that a
pawn off the board
so it may be something worth exploring
just take a look at it how do you know
what queen
yeah okay you just hit the rook and you
get because because the a file opens
yeah something like that the a file
opens
with a4 and rook d1 is always a threat
so it's not like the rooks have nothing
to do
they suddenly are working and i don't
know
i don't know that this is lost actually
with a4 coming on the next move
but somehow i prefer the rook and bishop
and game over
safer to be sure but you were asking me
if there was any alternative
yeah this might be an alternative to me
like now there are two there are two
ways you can choose from as black
when once upon a time it was uh which
coffin do you like
do you prefer to be cremated right right
this is this was your question before
and now you're actually
thinking possible defenses excuse me um
my will is written now but i'm not going
to use it just yet
this is amazing that this has even
occurred guys incredible
defense missing the rook h3 shot would
be huge for grizzchuk
and i like that maxim is spending some
time right now as well
gristuck is sitting there stewing inside
he's got to be thinking
this is some nonsense just happened i
had the victory
you're shaking your head and it's like
what he's alive
there are these other factors these x
factors and chess that distinguish
these grand masters i mean they're all
technically so proficient their openings
and so on and so on
but nerves you know nerves are
crucial and then i've always had that
difficulty when i get hit you know my
face turns red and
[Music]
getting you know back to reality
reoriented
you know it's usually taken me several
minutes
people like sasha you know he's this
time
trouble kind of guy and he he snaps back
right but mvl uh
his ability to find some of these moves
i mean his tenacity is amazing
frenchman amazing to calculate himself
out of trouble you can see how many
times they've appeared in the candidates
alexander grisham what a veteran
five appearances in the candidates some
of them
pretty deep runs right did he lose
against gelfand in the finals
that's right right that boris girlfriend
had to become
challenger he had to get past grisham
and yeah in the finals of that
candidates back when it was still a
knockout
fabiana carrano was three being the
second most experienced
uh this is his third appearance ding
liran anichigiri with two
each both playing in the previous one
and
uh a bunch of newcomers
alexenko but also mvl which for a lot of
people might be a bit surprising that
this is his first candidate
a big surprise that had not appeared
before
it's tough qualifying to this tournament
you can think of so many names
that are not in this event and you would
think well wait a second that guy
did participate in the last one he just
started
atrociously and never was able to
recover started with two losses in that
event
rookie rookie four and king b1 on the
board
and now we're gonna see rook h4 or are
we going to see a queen d5
slash c6 move played
just getting would be to play rook
h4 but i wouldn't be able to like
articulate exactly why
i prefer that end game so much i think
it's because the king safety
is just not as important whereas when
white still has a queen
maybe there's some things to be worried
about with my king on g8
well i think the critical question for
me is
are you worried about losing or are you
thinking maybe there might be some
chances
see i would still like to preserve my
chances with black but
quite honestly in both scenarios i feel
like black's still in the back foot
trying to make a draw
so let's take this position for example
after the move a4
uh what do you what do you feel about
this
the capture on d3 will happen
and then potentially rooks might show up
on the ranks
back rank second rank attacks are you in
so much danger here
you do have a past e pawn as well e4
could happen
at some point
i really wouldn't even feel any danger
if i had black right now yeah
i wasn't feeling the move um bishop c1
as much i think your passport you make a
good point it's
important and i think you have to play
rook g4 because if you play the rook
anywhere else g6 might
crush you right so you force important
sensible
but i think and he's going to go for
this end game
with the queens against the rooks
different approach than i would have
taken
but rook g4 bishop takes e5 i
i feel like yeah queen takes h1 let's
look at that position because we're
going right into it guys
yes we take on e5 in this position and i
just feel like white's better no bishop
takes e5 rook g5 queen b7
isn't this like really nice for white
what do you mean
it's important because i do have uh
a check a series of checks if you think
i'm hanging my bishop
no all grandmasters don't blunder do we
keep telling them that yeah
[Laughter]
so okay so this is the position hold on
yeah
okay we do have rook g4 on the board
guys so yeah
this is what i was thinking reach this
see bishop v5 already on the board so
we're predicting this pretty well
to me if if it's fine if you're better
but are there going to be any chances
that's the real question are there any
going to be any real chances
and this is if this is going to be
complex
you showed me that you couldn't beat me
when you were plus six
right like i was completely dead in the
water
am i so completely dead that i should be
afraid in this position
but you are definitely worse in my
opinion as black
can you complicate and create chances no
well i still want to i must still wanted
to play the move
a4 here but now you might take it you
all just take it thank you for the past
pawn right
here you might just sorry you guys
wanted to take it i apologize
i i would just i don't i don't quite
agree with this approach by maxime
i don't quite get it he's taken on g5
we're here
we're here we're expecting takes
now here the point is is this rook on
um uh d8 right so
can i try to set up
no i can't okay well i don't know
all right let's let's start with the
check let's go to
maybe a2 it seems a little bit safer
okay
let's nice trick let's let's uh
go for 27 on the board by the way then i
have to start consolidating
right something like queen e4 queen e4
rook to the seventh
yeah and this will just be a draw right
i don't know if it's
if in v2 or something yeah how
how weak is this pawn how weak is this
pawn
so if we get these types of positions
um let's say you're looking at h7
immediately i don't know if you need to
you can waste time
this feels like it's a draw right it
does it does
i agree maybe i misplayed it with white
at some point maybe king a2 was wrong
maybe i should go to b2
gain that tempo like rook d1 king b2
uh oh sorry uh yep rook d1 king b2
and just say you're not really worried
about the first rank because i always
have king a2 this bishop on e5 is really
powerful
great defender yes okay so you still
have to play rogue d2
uh hang just a second here maurice just
a
brief moment because i'm
uh fair enough um well
i'm a little bit worried about bishop f4
right if i go rook
to d2 then i'm like oops what if you
played
what if you had played uh rook d2 in one
move
instead instantly keeping this guy in
reserve
correct okay fair enough
i maybe bishop f4 the same move yeah
bishop f4 just tickling
well at least in this particular case
a1 isn't being defended that's the thing
like you have two rooks
two rooks are terrible for checkmating
anything if i still go something like
queen a8 and i start threading bishop h6
you don't really
move the rook from the d-file because of
bishop d6 i hit the a5 pawn
yeah yeah this looks like a
maybe a one result game i'm misplacing
my rooks is what it looks like
yeah bishop takes e5 brook takes g5
queen takes b7 is on the board
and maxine is down to eight minutes in
this
vitally important game let's just remind
people that
mvl with a victory would
be only a half a point out of first so
i mean you can't emphasize
how important this game is um but okay
how how to coordinate the rook's best
obviously how about this this is my
question bishop b4
what is that sorry what rook check
which rook sorry b1 or d1 rook d1 yeah
because i'm afraid i want to play bishop
b4
but i feel like if i play bishop b4 in
one move you have bishop b2
i mean i'm not sure you want to put the
king on b2
yeah okay okay now the nice part is as
far as checkmate on g7 is concerned the
bishop which was covering that square
we've also got a rook covering that
square so we're not worried
about any checkmate uh occurring on g7
now alejandro how do we reposition the
queen and so it's so nice
because c3 the the scene so totally
undesirable right so that's no
this is one of those what did you say a
moment ago alejandro the rooks don't
checkmate anything this is like they
don't
this is this is lifting your kimono i
wouldn't do that
i wouldn't do that c3 no
yeah so what happens here if your king
is put on be
pushed to b2 the rooks are finding the
works are coordinating with the bishop
to create options my only
oh oh i can play i was like i was
worried that bishop c3
bishop i am curious like why is your
bishop better on before except
optically well we're not sure yet
we're just uh yes i'm actually
completely not sure i just
i just wanted to bring i go something
like i i
i put my queen on e4 with with tempe no
i'm going to tell you the reason why
i'm going to tell you the reason why
right i'm going to tell you the reason
why alejandro
the reason why i was i was actually
threatening your bishop
right that's why i'm actually
threatening my bishop so queen g2
check uh was impos before with the
bishop on f8
i'm not threatening rook takes e5
because the queen two check
so that's why i moved the bishop so now
i am threatening rick takes e5 did i
have i don't know
i'm not even threatening again in this
position because you've got queen b a
check well
i'll fix that later i'm going to double
click okay alejandra has a very direct
idea he says well first of all let me
reposition my queen
okay on the more central outpost queenie
for check so now i've defended the
bishop
for the game in the tempo now all right
what's the
next follow-up though alejandro bishop
d4 i think
i want to actually see e8 kind of
or unless bishop f4 is immediately
something but
yeah maybe bishop f4 is also very
dangerous
because you've got queenie a check ideas
like something like this
you're forcing me to put my bishop back
on the passive square right
right and then here i can even hold on
to
[Music]
my pawn with e5 bishop e5 you get a very
similar position
but i feel like black's really tied down
i'm gonna wait rookie one here
yeah that's fine but that's the thing
black can make
a series of almost threats but the
coordination of the queen and the bishop
here is just so much better than the
rooks right it just feels it yes
so queen takes b7 and check this out
guys and again our apologies to
wang hao and cairo it's just that this
move
this game is just absolutely riveting
i should at least give a little respect
and it looks what do we have
first instincts per pet
okay let's go back and we're back here
looks like a perpet is a foot
in that game what if what if you
maintain the integrity of your position
and play the move rook to e8
and as soon as i said that he decided to
put his pencil squares
where he could be attacked potentially
[Laughter]
potentially we don't care about no
stinking integrity
you know i sounded so intelligent i know
i hate the integrity
yeah we need to
keep it wild keep it crazy all right
it's the commentator's curse
the commentator's curse is you will
never never in a million
years take the pawn he took the pawn
yeah i was trying to get to e2 but
by direct means without allowing the
queen to be able to go to b8 and
all the pinning issues that you were
talking about alejandro just
sidestep and say attack your bishop move
it now
and then go to e2 and then bring the you
know some kind of action like that or
check and bring the rook to g
i think that line was actually forcing
yeah
rookie 8. now you you'd won my heart
there
with integrity bishop c3 played by grace
remember that grisham doesn't have a lot
of time we're not that far from move 40.
remember we're 38. 38 but still grister
can't just fall asleep on the wheel
right
bishop c3 attacking that rook
we're anticipating rook check which is
kind i i guess he wants the king on b2
i'm not 100
sure why but that was why he would play
rook d2 right
or bishop can he play rookie two again
uh
just say okay you you you've got your
bishop on c3 good
well job well b4 is not going to happen
the pawn on a5 is defended and there's a
there's a rook g1 followed by rook g2
check threat
kind of that's right is it actually
defended
yeah okay
i don't know looks okay for you to
follow up guys
you need to fall out too why why is this
okay like i
just defend the spawn maybe like queen
f3 rookie two played by the way
rook e2 on the board uh
you def i missed that so you won f3 and
i defend like
king b2 and i put my queen on i don't
know f5 let's say
and you're do i have time to play bishop
b4
it's a good question actually right how
how do we evaluate that end game
not clear to me let's catch up with the
game though because they they
are playing differently than we are
calculating right now queen c8 was
played by grishok after rook e2
i think he's going to the same line same
line but you can take on a5
right it's not the same line it's not
the same like because if you go rook g1
king b2 rg2
or if you play rook duty immediately i
think i do take on in
either case i take and there's no
trickies at all and i've got this guy
covered uh
[Music]
so that's why he may have to keep his
rook on g5 bit
then what do we do for another turn
hmm
man i feel like i'm going to ask a
question and then my gran somebody's
going to take my grandmaster title away
from me
is that actually lost
which and just out of curiosity's sake
like rook g2 bishop a5
take take take taking h7 oh i mean it's
a legitimate question
why would we berate you for this one
i your grand master title away for lots
of other reasons
pretty okay i mean the time that you
didn't give me a night when i needed a
night in a bug house session
this looks winning actually yeah with
the bishop on e7 you kind of
do you what are you the guys looking at
this looks like a really uh
easy easy is it conversion no no i have
to get the bishop out of uh
the cage quickly the cage first but then
i probably don't have enough time to do
this
uh you mean after bishop how do you get
your bishop out of here no bishop c5 is
like there's some move like bishop
okay fine all right no no i'm gonna
start no i got an idea i got an idea
don't don't call me
no no i got a better idea you go check
okay
get into this line you go check king b2
rook g2
bishop a5 rook c2 queen c2 bishop a3
so you don't have bishop d8 at the end
king b1 oh so you get the taking h7
this end game how's this end game bishop
in here king 87 bishop d8 bishop doesn't
belong on a3 either
yeah it doesn't it's the same thing
there's your d8 still get trapped
yeah that's very sad
it was stylish but it would be very sad
twins the bishop is actually not better
at all on a3
i like the way you started with i've got
a much better idea
about a3 but we're going to do this guys
g2 play bishop a5 we expect right
yeah that's why he played bishop c3 and
queen i mean queen f5
if we're debating that bishop a5 for
executive is a draw queen f5 rook c2
must be a draw
so this is wow
what a i mean mvl has played remarkably
up to this moment is mvl saying do you
have a way of
continuing you know what the king the
king doesn't have to go to h7
you could keep the king out of you could
keep the bishop out of e7 because that's
the whole point
we're going down the line we're going
down the line you could you could keep
you could play king f8
and bring the king central and how do
you win that position
that's the that's a different argument
that's a whole different argument
wait wait wait you didn't play bishop
why didn't you play bishop a3 so you had
king and fate right that was the whole
point you go rook c2
you go rook c2 queen c2 bishop a3 that
was your point right maurice
king be one rookie two bishop a3 that
was bishop three a33
and we were just going along the line to
improve it here instead of playing king
h7 which is a disaster
because the bishop ends up on e7 you
play king f8
and bring the king to the middle and and
help
defend this way it's the same defense
that he's playing except with the
centralized king you didn't lose one
tempo but it's no big deal
in this position because the bishop
doesn't get to the critical e7 square
man if mvl now loses because of a subtle
momentary end game lapse he will smack
himself
this is incredible is it lost
well the game position the current
position
the you you can't get what you want
you're just a tempo
our great fear is that once we
establishes his bishop on e7
he'll anchor the pawn on f6 and then
he'll just choo choo
the ball away the board no you have to
move the bishop out you have to go
like bishop d6 i wish my bishop was on
a3
oh my god okay bishop to d6 but here i'm
too fast with the king right
king e4 i just like good king d3 king
faking e4
and i get all the way to d5
no way that's a draw a missing move one
oops tempo loss whoa
so everybody who may just be shortly
joining this
it was a this we think a swiss and zoo
right here may be the com the difference
between
drawing and losing bishop a3
check was an opportunity for black to
get his
pieces out so that his king could get to
e8
instead quickly captured
and whoopsie daisy
because okay let's see it again so
bishop d6
what happens guys d3
bishop plus bishop c3 gains a tempo here
oh bishop c3 gains the tempo i'm
thinking you're playing bishop d8 i
apologize
why couldn't you play bishop d.a there
it also probably works but bishop c3 i
think is immediately winning
i think you're right okay hold on hold
on just a second let's just see this
again
so if i go king f8 now
but can you play king c4 right no way
you survive with the king on t5 right
okay just go ahead and click and yeah
before
physically going right i get my pawn all
the way to b6 by force
and to be seven by fours
i mean that counts
my king could get to b7 just a second
just like just a second
so if my king no my king yeah
i get to b7 your king gets to c6 you
have to keep moving the bishop
it's over yeah you just play b6 you go
b7
b7 and then bishop back to e5 and i
think bishop back to b4 is the easiest
but this will work too yeah no no not
like that trying to do this
and this also doesn't work man this wins
it doesn't have
everything is winning the b-pawn is
simply going up the board
so again i'm just going to flash back
and forth this is the current position
and we didn't we we think that king h7
bishop d8
is easy for white and we think that
bringing this marches it's just too slow
because the king gets to d5 in a
previous version let's just
should we just double check uh our
would how what can it fade here yeah
yeah if i get my king to d5
isn't it no but now no no two because we
should be two here
when the king gets to d5 you have bishop
b2 this is very important yeah
absolutely no question absolutely
no tempo lost you know what's crazy
we talk about the gristrok rule if you
have time on the clock use it no matter
how obvious the situation
right that's the grisham rule if we go
back
to when he played rook takes on c2 the
first time we check
that was move 41 oh no queen takes c2
he had a full hour
to think about the position where we
where you might
you might say does bishop a3 make a
difference let me just
analyze right let me just let me just
analyze that's what grisham would have
done
rich you'd have said bristok why are you
thinking about rookie two grisham might
not even have taken on c2
on the previous move after bishop he
might have stopped here and said oh you
know what it's move 40.
it's move 41. let me breathe a second
and analyze
he might have gone into a 10-minute
think and we'd be like what is christian
thinking about
yeah i've got alternatives i got
alternatives
[Music]
what he did mvl just said eh i'm just
gonna play what i saw
i got the extra hour i i'm just not even
gonna use it it would be a waste of time
at this moment
and boy he wishes he had paused for just
one second
and considered the situation to take a
little bit longer look here because
he literally just blundered away the
whole game
and the championship and the chance to
have any chance of the championship
by the way uh the more i am looking at
this position the more i
am thinking that black did have
alternatives to rook takes c2 i'm
not a hundred percent sure but rook f2
you can't play bishop b4 because then
i'll play rook takes c2
there was alternatives and mvl
right here he didn't hesitate he
recaptured
actually i don't i don't think there
were alternatives yesterday there wasn't
no because rook after you go bishop d8
rook f2 you go bishop to d8
i think that's game over
i'm not gonna i disagree because it just
but why exactly is a
game over am i i'm sure i'm missing
something but
i mean there should be e6
bishop b6 now can i
ah but now you can maybe do this
i don't know uh but definitely the
moment
has passed because uh
he did not take your statement you
didn't say there were
great alternatives you just said there
were alternatives that's right
you know i cannot think why not just
stop it why not think
it's worth it you weren't just looking
for a second because you're going down
a completely forcing line where you're
upon down and you better know the
evaluation of the position
when you get here if you're sucking your
rooks here with all your time on the
clock it was move 40
when he put when he played rook gg2 he
it was move 40 and he had two and a half
plus minutes on the clock from what i
remember
right so when you play this move let's
move forward he just took on a5
get the water take a moment stretch a
little bit
okay maybe it's not gonna work out maybe
it's just a draw
let me make sure i'm not making any
mistakes all right we're going to spend
10 minutes here as a professional
and look at the position and make sure
i'm not overlooking nuances
so i have a swizzuk i can play rook c2
and i have a swish inside and i have a
bishop a3 is that gonna
matter i'm not really sure consider that
but i should be looking at it
what did he do i'm just gonna make the
moves and get there because it must be a
draw
oh man wow oh wow
and he has played king h7 on the board
by the way
we are we are are we 100 sure this is
winning
i mean obviously i think bishop a3
improves your position let's not right
kid
yes right bishop a3 is just a better
version and everything we said is true
because you should be thinking
but how sure are we that this is winning
like a hundred percent
well if you're gonna i would say i would
and let's just say i do it in the worst
possible way so that
even if i give you all that you could
possibly have a great king
and i'm just because i'm just seeing
that in those
previous positions we're analyzing guys
i'm just seeing the b-pawn
make a touchdown i mean you said oh i
get the pawn to b6 and
b7 and i went oops
you know you got that far oops that's a
bad boy
what you need what you need is effort
that to be a c pawn
maybe even an a pawn or definitely an a
pawn
or a c pawn but not a b pawn because the
queening square
is a dark square and that's that's the
worst thing you could want if you wear a
c
pawn if you're an a pawn you draw
immediately
because you could just rush your king
over to the a the a8 square and sack
your bishop for the f pawn
and then you'd have the wrong color
bishop it were a c pawn your king is
headed straight to c8
and you're wondering how do you win that
one
it looks like you could actually sack in
a timely fashion on f6
there as well white would have a lot of
work but the b-pawn
it's the perfect pawn against that dark
square bishop the perfect one
this is the one point if if any pawns
winning
that's the one right you can actually
pick any pawn along the
all the files i'm looking at it and the
h pawn the g pawn the f
any one of those the worst one black
wants to see
for this opposite color i mean this
similar color bishop construction
is the b-pawn queening on that dark
square that's the worst one you want
and white and for white the best one
like thank you
guys i'm going to give this game a quick
break
i just want to go into the game of carol
for just a moment to see
if a perpet has been played it sure
looks to me
i'm seeing a lot of checks i don't see a
result yet but i'm just seeing a lot of
checks even if there's no perpet
is either side playing this for a win no
we expect this to draw
hey guys i think now is kind of a good
time for a commercial because i think
we've
actually hit a lull i am expecting a
draw here and i am expecting in this
game
the players their awareness to grow that
this position is just
busted us what do you think he's going
to sit for a while
i don't i don't deny that a break is a
good idea
it's possible resignation might happen
at any moment but at least one game will
be going on
so let's say we go on break don't be
surprised folks if maxim actually
resigns the position i would be crazy
surprised
i think he'll think for an hour before
he resigns
maybe so but i wouldn't be stunned
either either way
it works let's see let's get on a break
back to looking at these standings
you may have heard about st louis's
world-class museums
art history science even
magic you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play
with a 10-story slide and a ferris wheel
on top
don't let all this family fun slide by
you
[Music]
those kids it is st lou is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever that we stay
connected to carry on that mission
we are currently offering 24 weekly
classes online through our youtube and
twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative
digitally
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay
safe and continue to watch play and
enjoy the game of chess
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team
on the very first year of the team's
inception slu obtained second best
university at the pan american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st louis
university
professional golf returns to saint louis
in 2021
the ascension charity classic presented
by emerson
stars like phil mickelson ernie else jim
furyk and more compete at norwood hills
country
club september 6 through the 12th
tickets clubhouse passes
hospitality suites and pro am foursomes
are on sale now all proceeds go to north
st
louis county charities visit
ascensioncharityclassic.com or call
eight two eight 314-938-282 eight pga
tour golf is back in the loo
the ascension charity classic
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession
isn't a notepad camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility a journalist's work
revolves around the truth
finding it verifying it and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts
into context examining all the arguments
and including
differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories offering
facts that may have been omitted
we work every day to earn your trust
for news turn to st louis public radio
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital
and preeminent global destination for
lovers of the sport
we look forward to seeing you in our new
space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 us chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the sinkfield cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody we are here it's round
11 of the candidates current standings
with
already a couple of games finished jane
pomnyacci held fabiano corona to a draw
even though
young had the white pieces and he leads
the tournament but his lead has shrunk
as anishkiri just obliterated dingleran
over the board and he finds himself only
half a point behind
maxima sherlock graph is doing his best
to try to survive the current position
he has against chris
and say that he still has a chance in
this event a loss would put
an end to his hopes for sure meanwhile
wang hao is still fighting against
kirill alexenko
remember the schedule we have around
tomorrow and then our second rest day
the game the tournament will probably
finish
off with games 13 and 14 with on april
26th and 27th
with playoffs if necessary on april 28th
guys i was taking a look at this
position
on the break even throwing in bishop a3
table bases say winning for white
yeah and as we return to uh play
i also on our break did take a quick
look
and just to see what the engine said
plus 15
and i was like oh so yeah bishop a3
would not have
changed matters but it was complicated
though it did let's let's um
show everybody that moment where
uh it was right here that after rook
takes
c2 the time control had been made queen
takes c2 and this is the moment where we
thought the swish and zoo
made all the difference it didn't and
explain why alejandro
well apparently the important thing is
to kind of control
black's pieces and after king f8 which
was the move that we liked
right the idea and the that you have to
find is king c3
which is a little bit uh counter
yes king e8 and here the point is to go
bishop b4
ah and you're not on time to attack the
pawn on f6 right
no you gain that tempo you go bishop c1
you go
king c4 king
let's say d7 and kind of amazingly
this is important again because king d5
bishop b2 fails
yeah and this is apparently some sort of
draw you have to go to b5
come on b five yeah you hold on to the
f6 spawn
and you put the king on the a file and
push the other one
difficult moves to find these are not
absolutely
obvious moves but i understand why you
want to get the king to a6
as soon as possible in order to give the
b
pawn the the grand escort there i get
that
but yes king c3 followed by bishop b4
king c4 and king b5
uh very ultra precise moves would have
still done it huh
yes nice and by the way i mean those
moves again
accentuate the fact that the b-pawn is
the key in this ending
right yeah winning the game
amazing the truly remarkable sequence
there
playing the king to c3 the bishop to b4
and the king to b5 those are three 2 900
moves in a row
right there that's like what yeah
really are you kidding me you've got to
get them right yeah yeah
that's that's the difference between a
draw and a loss right
drawn to absolutely sorry you know it's
funny
because mvl had a real chance
to draw against fabi actually draw on
the board
and missed the setup and had but here
had a real chance to make it
extraordinarily difficult
for grishook table-based level difficult
right uh where we are unable to just say
oh just this this and this we got the
procedure down
you need some super accurate ideas in
order to win that game and once again
slipping both both night offs
not getting the luck of the night off on
his side everybody's testing him there
and once again his favorite is pet
opening
leading to end games that maybe well
middle games that look as difficult near
death
end games that look potentially tenable
and that's where he's losing them
actually funnily enough that's true yeah
he's losing them in the end game
after suffering difficult middle games
both times
and maybe that's the truth of of the of
the opening right
maybe you'll survive the opening maybe
you'll be okay
maybe you'll find some line that that
somehow miraculously
holds on by your fingernails but
somewhere you're gonna slip
and because of the time pressure or
because of the difficulty
of defending all the way through and
there you go
you go over the edge uh
you you just like uh presented this
beautiful point that i i really
do enjoy making i make it very often
is when i think about uh world champions
uh
great world champions i think great end
game players to my mind uh vasily
smithslav to choose one
was a great end game player anatoly
karpov really a great end game player
magnus carlson bobby fischer
great engineer vladimir krumnick great
end game players right
and i'm just thinking that uh you know
like
that there are you know also rants you
know really great
players mvl is a great great player i'm
just wondering uh
about his ending i i don't doubt his
abilities at all i think he's great
some of his end game play well we've
just seen a couple of examples
unfortunately he's under rather harsh
light
and in the example we just saw but uh
alejandro jump in who have you
admired over the course of
your studies and said geez i wish i
could play end games like that guy
shear off i think sexy
yeah i think it's highly underestimated
because when we think of sheer
fire on the board and tactics and all
these sacrifices and stuff but honestly
he is one of the best end game players
of all time if you see
his end games he was very clean very
technical very precise and his
calculation
allowed him to play some brilliances in
the end game i mean remember one of the
best moves of all time bishop h3 against
topalov
his tactical prowess allowed him to play
some beautiful beautiful end games
and he not only that had really good
technique during them at his
in when he was number two in the world
so
for me it was alex's issue of growing up
in the 90s seeing his games and saying
look
wait this guy is not just tactics yeah
well gary caspar
had that quality as well gary kasparov
you might think well gary opening
novelties
vicious attacks blow you off the board
but again his ability to calculate
he could drop some good end games on you
as well you had already been so
so devastated by the blows that got to
the end game
that you might just oh it's technique
it's nothing special
and your eyes were lit up by the tactics
the same way you said about shuroff
gary put some some main game put you out
you're dead
don't move anymore it's over lay down
how about that move that karpov played
in the end game against gary kasparov in
a world championship
g2 knight g2 yes instantly like it
he put that on the board and gary went
oh dear
oh dear oh some great end game players
and you know
uh defense wins championships too asked
magnus carlson
as did you say capoblanca by the way did
we say i didn't
i didn't say how could we talk about a
world champion with great
game players of all mention thank you
very very very good okay uh
unfortunately
for mvl and i don't know what
is happening on the clock let me just go
back and forth here for a quick second
uh why is the game rather frozen
what is it because chris circus
christchurch christian and
he's thinking for 22 minutes on this
position he's taking a sweet time
i think alkaline doesn't make a
difference though i mean it just
it feels like white can't lose this
can't
cannot not win he goes king here
puts his bishop here puts his king here
and pushes his pawn home
is there any thing wrong with this idea
well when you put it that way excuse me
what is the
what is the grishtrong rule why are we
not following the rules
if you have time use it maybe even
abuse it it's a gristrick way
spend some time and look if maxime we
said it followed this rule you might
have found a
tough resource in bishop to a3 but he
didn't
grishtruck will spend time even on
obvious captures
grishok will spend some time and get
himself right so he
did he have a win earlier in this game
was it only one
yeah was it two was it three well giz
had so many chances
that he blew that can you blame him if
he stops and looks at
the end game even when it's pretty
simple and straightforward looking
the last time we remember him blowing it
was playing rook takes h5
instead of alejandro's rook to h3 h3
right i mean we remember that he
remembers that
he's not trying to blow another game
he's not trying to blow another chance
uh he wants to stop and look here by the
way for those who are joining us late
what uh maurice just referenced was that
in this
moment alexander grisha
played the move rook takes h5 on move
31 and it's strange it's
the queen is the one who wants to take
on
h5 and alejandro suggested
rook h3 keeping the square unoccupied
as a difference maker as it happened in
the game rook h5 this looked crushing
queen h2 rook h8 mate but there was this
extraordinary move
of rook d4 and after rook h1
again the queen wants to get to h5 if he
if he had played queen h2
there was this check that made
all the difference in the world and it
was rook d4
that allowed maxine to crawl back into
the game
unfortunately for maxine fans it is it
ain't going to be enough
because we do have oops let me make sure
i think
these are my moves not grishik's moves
we do have a losing end game
for mvl at the moment on the board
to me practically also i don't know if
he didn't see it or if he evaluates it
differently than i did
but i felt the danger of the two rooks
against the queen
and maybe this point where maxime could
have gone rook h4
instead of i think queen d5
right here uh sorry
um yes in this moment we were
we were thinking that there's two
crucial ways of playing uh one was
queen d5 which was the game and it went
into two rooks versus queen
and the alternative was a really tough
one as well
was to trade queens get the queens off
the board something you were finding for
alejandro and going into this
uh maybe difficult ending we'll just
leave it at that for the moment but at
least for the queens off the board
uh you felt that this was better better
chances for black than the game
absolutely i
challenge you to actually even win a
pawn right i'll try to be solid put a
pawn on b6 a bishop on c5 and
try to hold on fortress style you do
have a button on f6 that i can always
attack
i'm not thrilled about my king don't get
me wrong but
hey it's maybe not the end of the world
well because
unfortunately what we did see instead
was a situation where it was very
awkward for black to coordinate his
rooks
while maintaining his king position and
after the move bishop takes a5 it's
immediately self-evidence it's a two
result game
and here rook seat two
there was an alternative maybe rook here
or rook here
and just keeping the position for a
moment by the way i'm
told that grishard still hasn't moved
wow really crazy
um
there seems to be such a direct route
uh to victory i i'm a little curious
what i
what what do you think he's
i think it's just calculating till the
end over and over i mean
what what is spending another half hour
just to make sure that you're actually
winning right
right when you calculate it all out just
you'll play it instantly
i mean our very first impression was
just put the bishop on e7 and push the
guy home
uh our second impression is you didn't
even need to do that
maybe maybe the bishop is much better on
e7 than on c3 it
it is after all anchored they both win
so
it's kind of yeah that's that's the way
i feel with
they both win what's the problem
and we'll have more chess after the
candidates remember that the grand
chess tour is coming back after your
hiatus
we have the first classical tournament
of the grand chess tour
in romania it'll be june 3rd to the 15th
super bad chess classic held in
bucharest that's going to be very
exciting some of the best players in the
world many of which are playing in this
tournament
we'll be following it up with the blitz
and rapid portions paris croatia
almost back to back there um
those are gonna be great i actually
particularly love uh
the paris tournament great memories from
there
and we're gonna finish the tour here in
saint louis with the st
louis rapid and blitz followed
immediately by the classical sing field
cup
those are great tournaments chaz is back
guys and we're gonna have all the action
for you
i'm really looking forward to these
events me too
i'm really happy to see the players play
over the board events like
this one in fact but the singfill cup
ever since it's
it came to being in 2013
has been the greatest event on american
soil as far as i'm concerned and what a
series and i'm looking forward to the
sinkhole cup very very very much as well
as the
grand chess tour hopefully we'll be all
able to call the action
all together in a studio that would be
nice
that would be ideal certainly
it's been a year of online commentary
and online games and
well there's big plans there's a lot of
tournaments coming up that
hold a lot of importance uh world cup
also happening in a couple months that's
going to be a big one
exactly you as we were coming on uh
on air you were you were telling me
about a tournament that's taking place
on the st louis campus and you didn't
even know about it
uh do do share that with our american
viewers
because it might be important for them
to try to qualify for the
world cup 128 player knockout uh
it's an increase to 156 this year
and i didn't know that's right it's a
more
world league cup as the top federations
the top i think 80 or 100 federations
get to
choose a player to represent them and
there are on top of that
qualifiers to the event and the americas
qualify our continental will be played
in a hybrid system one of the new
feed a ways of playing chess in which
everybody from one country will be
in the same room arbitered by an
international arbiter
but you still play online so that way
you can still participate against
players from all over the continent
and the top eight players of that event
which will be held in may 22nd here in
st louis
uh for the american players uh will
determine uh who qualifies to the world
cup to represent
uh the americas and is that a swiss
invitational the qualification is a
knockout
it's a knockout and you can play that
online but you have to play it in person
and you have to go to st louis and the
st louis university to do that
that's right okay wow
how exciting are you going to play i'm
i'm already preparing
the answer is yes and yes nice
very nice how about you uh maurice so
you're going to throw in some patties
i don't even know this thing existed
until you said that
so you're not preparing okay
i i imagine the answer to that is no but
i you know i want to
get back to the standings yes and
the road ahead for some of these players
okay right now we're see we're thinking
mvl's gonna lose this game
it looks right it looks bad which will
bring grishook
tied with him at five and a half points
right yep
at 50 right they'll both be at 50
now if we're gonna talk percentages
that boy still got the best chance but
anish is searching
i mean right he's got to feel great and
feel like he could
win another game but he did
lose to nippa in the very first round
right is that correct says he lost to
nepo that means a win
by him if he goes plus one and nepo
breaks even
he loses the event that's right yeah
congrats you win another game know what
so what so
he's actually in in reality a full point
behind
it looks like he's only i haven't behind
nepal behind nepo he's actually a full
point behind nepo
if they tie it's not going to work out
for him
but take it and they don't play and they
don't they don't play each other at all
coming up because of what you said about
the road ahead for the players at the
top of the show taking a peek ahead to
tomorrow's round how big is that
bob versus aneesh bobby versus aneesh
but let me say this
you say how big is it i'm not really
sure how big that pairing is
it's clearly a big pairing but the
problem
the problem is that uh anish
like he doesn't really have to have to
win although winning would be huge like
i mean but it's not like he completely
has to win
does fobby winning do anything i guess
fabi winning
because fabi winning actually
makes it better for nepo right if nepo
draws his game
because you bobby winning make it better
for nepo i don't think so oh
no because remember that fabi will have
tie break
over nepo right they're equal on the
head to head
they are equal a number of victories
assuming that
uh fabi catches i'm not talking i'm not
talking about the that's exactly what
i'm talking about you make
your point is fabi wins anish
is done yeah that's over
anish is no longer chasing it's over he
can't win
it's just over if nepo draws and fabi
wins that game
there's only one person for nepo to look
at and it's fabi
there's nobody else right right fabi is
a full point behind so nepo
i mean who do you want to win if you're
an epo
you want fabi to win you want to draw
you you want to draw you want
to draw a bill but listen a draw
a draw by the two of them still leaves
both of them within range of you
a win by fabi kills a player which one
do you prefer
you're going to be a half a point ahead
of somebody would you rather be a half a
point ahead
of one and one point ahead of two or do
you want to be
or do you want one guy to be gone but
no the other guy i'm happy wait a minute
wait wait wait wait wait wait
i'm really happy to answer the question
i want to draw
yeah i definitely got for sure because i
think anish
drawing gets rid of him that gets rid of
him because that puts anisha point
behind
and the other guy that i'm really really
afraid of fabiano
i keeps him a point behind me so yeah i
think if i'm nepo i'd love to see
fabi and anish make a draw and that'd be
like just fine that'd just be fine
so what happens what happens if you
i guess i'm wondering if if there are
two players within range
one guy i'm worried about is fabi
because if bobby beats anish and he's
only half a point behind him we saw it
in berlin
what did fabby do in berlin in this most
grueling
exhausting double round robin event he
wins his last two games
to surge and become challenger yeah so
i'm saying if i'm nep
you know keep that guy at a
arm's length difference yeah i agree
especially with anish having the worst
tiebreaker would rather have
a niche be the the closer pursuer right
and because of the tiebreak grizzstruck
after our long thing
is going straight into what we thought
was the cleanest
win king d3 put the bishop on c3 put the
king on c4
push that guy make sure that you start
with the king
not with the with the pawn you can play
b4 in this position
we will play before in this position
we're waiting for maximus move
but the idea is of course you first get
your king to the a file and then you
start pushing the pawn and
we didn't find anything no
no we we sure did bishop is just doing a
fantastic
job of course you can win back the pawn
but by the time you take that bond
this b-pawn just goes trotting happily
all the way up the board and home so
the one thing that we'd hoped previously
is like
somehow the black king would be
somewhere near
this zone let's say on the c6 square but
well frankly he's just not getting it
there
it's that simple black's king is too far
away and
uh white is ready to uh
coordinate the victory but let's take a
look at the road ahead uh
for these players uh maurice well we've
got nepo
and he's got wang hao tomorrow
and actually basically he has maxim
sandwich between the chinese contingency
and
we see there uh it looks like wang is
the
is a dangerous player of course he beat
him
in the first half he also beat ding
lorraine in the second half
and maxine will he have any kind of
stomach for playing chess
after he loses today and his chances
just simply derailed he will go down
in flames with only a chance to win
out if he's going to have any
opportunity to do this
i don't know those those look like good
pairings i would say for nepal
that's that's something that he would
like to have going into the last three
games
although i would also say those don't
look like three draws those look like
the kind of battle tested players wild
enough
that anything could happen except maybe
in the last round with dingler and not
playing great
but those next two rounds are going to
be crucial we see fabi playing against
geary big time game their ding against
chris
christchurch
will grishchuck have any desire to play
wild chess but with black against
dingler in maxime wounded
against alexenko will you just go for it
though
that's the lowest rated player in the
tournament but he's still kind of far
right if he wants to keep his chances
alive he needs to win
even that i don't see it one power
against netball no
nbl nbl has to win out
yeah i think he's got a beat he's got to
win alec against alexenko
and win against against nepal those two
muslims
must be done looking at the standings
he's got to do
both in which case if he can pull that
off a win against nepo if nepo doesn't
win tomorrow
he would be tied with demo with two
wings right five and a half would
suddenly make seven and a half
so nebo draws and maxim wins so mexican
only takes one day at a time
win the next game and go for it all
against nepo
and then looking at fabian anish they're
sitting
pretty ahead of him but they need to
also get a
point in anish's case and a point and a
half
in fabi's case to keep pace so maxim's
chances are still there
two wins is the deal tomorrow is must
win
mustering and then the next day is also
mustafa
but i think the way we're seeing things
is that the difference between anish and
fabi
for practical purposes is the same to
napo right now right because the
nation's a point behind and five is a
point behind
correct even though it says half a point
there
the thai breaks we come back to these
thai breaks
the head-to-head between nepamiachi and
geary favors the russian
so it's a full point behind if you want
to see it from a practical point of view
of anish they're going to go all out
guys tomorrow is a do or die
for so many players and i'm i'm sitting
here suffering with alexander grishard
i mean again that game that he lost to
carol one that could
easily have gone in his favor i mean how
important was that game because
i mean if you already chalk up the
victory for sasha in this game
he would be at 50 percent if he hadn't
lost a carol
he would be at plus one if he had won
against carol he'd be a plus
wow i mean it's
some tension filled uh first rounds uh
of this
second half we've just seen the move b4
on the board too hey guys
um what is what is anishi's road ahead
we've been talking about this
who doesn't get in the livestream
tomorrow
that's a big dog but i don't recall him
having heavy hitters in the last two
rounds
i mean they're all heavy yeah
who's like look look there's
there are people you'd rather play i
mean would you like to play anish right
now
no no definitely not the answer is no so
luckily for any she cannot play himself
let's see the road ahead for him
uh dingley wren he did win that game
today
he will be playing with black against
fabiano he will be playing with black
against chris chuck and he finishes with
white against alexenko if that's
that is the pairing you want that's what
i'm watching
i guess okay we're talking about heavy
hitters they're all strong
but you gotta say white against alexenko
let's keep that in my back pocket
do i need to beat caruana do i need to
be here
for me yeah right yeah there we go here
we go everybody got
white in that last round and he's his tr
his handlers are circling now and saying
you might have to win this game right
here okay
this one right here we're going to
prepare as much as possible
and hope he pulls off what he did
against nepo
and make it nice and easy for you all
right so we're going to circle that one
but look those other two tabbies bobby
on the other hand
uh he does have a niche tomorrow
and two and two games again you say
there's some chances in there in the mix
those two players are not the draw
meisters who are going to just
settle things down shut it down easy
draws
how you going to say ho ho ho hold on
circle those two
uh i'll have my chances after all didn't
he famously beat
jerk in was it christian in berlin
berlin and with that it was the last
game to finish the
the event and there you go declined to
draw decline to draw
remember pleasant memories maybe
absolutely
there's still a lot to play for i'm not
sure tomorrow's game i think it's super
important
but it's not hyper must-win
critical nepo is three has three games
left
against three diverse type of
players but especially that maxime game
might nepo trip all we need is a trip
just one little
hiccup well there we go he's got destiny
in his hands that's for sure
we have a profile on janne pomnyachi
let's take a look
russian superstar yonder palmici is now
atop the leaderboard he was not
considered one of the top two favorites
in the event but his scintillating win
against anish giri
followed by some powerful blows against
the two chinese players
has now put him in a beautiful situation
moving forward will he be able to close
the deal
or will he collapse under the enormous
pressure
we will see as this star tries to bring
home
the possible challengers title to his
country
all right guys we have a move by mvl
bishop d6
i still think king b5 is winning
although with the
bishop kind of awkwardly post on d6 i'm
also wondering if i can just play b5
here
yeah i'm thinking uh the same way as you
i'm thinking he's just gonna play b5
because
if you can go b5 b6 and then post your
king
why not right i mean get that pawn as
far up the board as you possibly can and
after b5
if black goes back with the king well
this is a very
suggestive move put your king on d5 put
your bishop
on e5 so that you can play b6 that looks
really straightforward the only question
is
you know have i slipped and missed
something yeah
king b5 but i don't want it requires any
subtlety i think it's just
b5 and then the b pawn just lands it's
like a ton
of bricks as it just goes right up the
board it's just right there
there's some cute geometrics about a b
pawn please by the way
and for one thing it's
it's very difficult uh a lot of times
when you have a past
pawn uh and a bishop and it's bishops
battling to make uh to make the
promotion happen
it's very difficult to actually queen
the pawn clean
right what you're actually trying to do
is win the piece
because it's very it's very difficult
with accurate play for
this the defending side's piece to just
be to be put out
be ejected completely and then you
simply
cannot uh you simply cannot stop a queen
from happening
and it's going to be a queen on the
board so what i mean is
let's say let's make a couple of moves
uh get get the pawn of b7
and he's played b5 let's get the pawn to
b7 yes and
with a let's put the let's put the oh
he's resigned i can't even
let us lecture for another another time
save that scintillating point because
the guy reached
but you did want to say that the
blockading square if you get your king
what
maybe let's play king just put get the
just play some
just play some moves for black don't
move don't bring the king in no no don't
bring the king leave the
the king on e6 let's see and uh
and and get the king down well the
problem is the king is just going to go
marching to c6
the pawn to b7 and the bishop here he uh
envious i don't see anything he can do
about no no that's not true
that's not okay that's not exactly true
like
do do what you just said okay okay
keep going and now i bring the bishop
back bishop a5
and i so now see so now this is the
point
i can't take your pawn because bishop c7
bishop a7 right now this is the unique
thing about
the bish the b pawn right or maybe it's
also true of the c
pawn as well the limited space that this
bishop has
if you if it were a d-pawn the bishop
would be dancing along the diagonals
yes right but this it just so happens
that you
the bishop and pawn are not enough to
to simply queen the pawn you need more
help
and the fact that this bishop is
restrained by
uh the a file like there's no extra
diagonal
this was my point that the geometric of
that you just
don't force a queen home unless you get
all kinds of additional help or in this
case
just a king showing up on e6 and
dominating that bishop
if we shift the pawn over to the d-file
then you can't trap the bishop
you you have to you have to win it as a
straight piece it's like so it matters
which pawn we're using right and that's
that was my point yeah that that makes
it easy
the the bishop's diagonal is so short
on the a7 b8 diagonal as opposed to say
the d8
a5 diagonal has more squares if the
bishop on a7 can just get hit by the
king on
on a6 guys this is a fantastic victory i
mean let's face it for
alexander grishock his his stock went up
and for nbl fans that was just like the
worst
the worst crush uh i disagree with the
stock
the stock going up the stock to me that
somebody
stock who went up uh went down horribly
is mvl
they have the same score they're 50
they're out of the 20
as far as i'm concerned i mean i was
thinking unless they win all their games
yeah that's what it is i think great to
win all their games grishock has more of
the destiny
in his hand but again i just want to say
for mvl this is like
nightmare i mean you know he's had a
year to
relish the fact that he was tied for
first
and uh as there was a wonderful article
by alexa milinski and he talked about
the historical candidates tournament
this double round robin format
check it out on chess.com and he
basically was making the points
that since 2013 uh
and the current uh candidates double
round-robin tournament
usually in the first half there's been
two leaders
but one of them fades away mvl was just
hoping it wouldn't be him
and it's like the history you know
repeating itself
yeah actually i just i just again
thought about it grishard's chances are
actually worse than mvls
really because maxine plays nepo
richard already played nipple maxine
plays nepa
maxim can take destiny into his own
hands and
and knock nepo down crystal can't touch
like who does grisham end up playing in
the rest of the tournament because
he plays fatty right he plays and he
plays
right and so he plays fabian anis so he
can continue to play spoiler
for his countrymen frenchman out the way
whoop
maybe bobby let's try to knock them all
off
it will be beyond the chance i mean if
you knock everybody up
[Laughter]
he'll take the victory crown the
challengers uh for himself
no i mean actually i think he plays uh
grishak's road ahead is that he plays
anish
and then fabi in the last round he's
another player though there's a third
yes he's playing tomorrow against one
how
plays the chinese chinese players and
nba just had the pairings
and then two of the people who are going
to try to kill him gary
in the last story they're going to try
to kill him
so i i don't i don't see grystruk as
having
much of a hope in this tournament but
one player who's got a hope against hope
is maxine
gotta win tomorrow excuse me better do
it
and then when he gets his chance against
nepo that's
it better do it again that's right there
you gotta do it again
those are some pretty steep odds but at
least there's that remote chance can he
bring himself together
the way he's playing in this tournament
so far do any of us believe it
form has not been great no it hasn't and
the way he is i want to say mangled
abused his time
his time control his time his use of the
clock has just been
horrifying i mean if i was a second i'd
be in a hospital
a heart attack by the way we still have
a game going on and
carol wang how
essentially is saying hey i'm a pawn up
i'm ready to play on uh
let's let's continue the game now how
much
is this extra pawn super meaningful or
not
guys well the king so exposed and your
extra pawn being e5
i'm gonna go with no kind of doubt i
doubt it as well right
maybe just something as simple as like
queen c7 and in case of h3
take the darn pawn i like centralizing
but i think that every move is good but
queen b3 queen d5 i
i thought it was kind of the the
most direct because i didn't see how you
defend e5
comfortably i love but
is that why you dropped c5 right yeah
and then h3
might take just a second just a second
let me catch up with you guys
okay now
what do we want to do are we can we get
anywhere near you
by the way no i want sorry to be party
pooper for just a second
anything no you do after queen d3 you do
play e4
i was about to say that queen d3 if i
could force a trait of queens in
favorable circumstances that would be
easy draw but yeah
um sorry you were here
so what i want to do is i want to
somehow be able to fork your
king and bishop so tweet f3 check
yeah or queenie for check one of the two
right
all right let's do queenie fortune yeah
let's do a question but when you fire
queen e3
well where where is my king going first
i guess i can can i run away can i dance
i'm just gonna go to e1 i don't see why
one
ah you won you have one play queen h1
right sorry sorry yeah yeah
that was the one point yeah
even that i'm not sure actually can i
allow that king you want queen h1 king
e2
queen h2 i know you have g3 at the end
queen f2 g3
oh that would be beautiful oh
that's that's the shower
chill the coldness the
the why am i such an idiot feeling
we all know that feeling oh we do uh
again maybe not to e1 right you go yeah
two you were saying okay so d2
somewhat exposes but what i'm looking
the reason i'm bringing this up is i'd
like to be able to
uh to take advantage of this bishop
sitting on
um e5 at some point a little tactic
against
this bishop can i let's just take on h2
on h3 with something now is probably the
i think it's
i think it's the pawn that i wanted to
because if you think with the
queen because you're like one one step
away
yeah one two two okay now can you take
on i don't think you could take on this
i just don't believe it can you really
do this
of course i can it's legal but uh
why wouldn't i be able to what if i play
queen f5
i think i got queen d1 king d1 oh no i'm
too far away
and i'm too far away that's kind of
unfortunate
i'm trying to trade queens right well
you can trade queens if you're trying to
trade queens yeah
but am i on time you're saying that uh
you're not gonna get to h1
or are you i think you're going to get
there actually
i think that's a draw i think this is a
ah because i still have a b pawn that b
pawn against the dark square bishop
shows up again different circumstances
but but it looks like there's no way to
push
i'm going to put my king to f3 and then
i'm going to push my pawn
yeah without the pawn it's a loss right
because you get zuzwan you go king g6
right
king f5 but with the pawn i think it's
just an easy i could
yeah i can use it as a distraction to be
fair
i'm not really sure we had to go into
such details to make a draw for
what yeah
but we do have this position on the
board maurice yeah yeah oh
we're looking at queen c5 h3 right
h3 is probably the only idea yeah but
but here in this position
why don't we just like when we fight the
players
the queen f2 looks easier right why are
we cheesier
why are we complicating our life wait
wait queen e4
yeah and came back queen d3 king you won
yeah queen d three king
one yeah g one maybe even now
yeah doesn't look like much no and not
when i've got different
checks suddenly ready to appear either
and by the way queen c5
on the board oh boy
i tell you uh there's something special
about
the candidates tournament to be frank
i don't like the world championship
cycle i'm not a big fan of the world
championship cycle
at all i think winning the candidates
tournament eight
players double round robin is a very
very fair system
but for the challenger i mean you know
there's only one place you've got to win
the event and it's
very very tough to become
challenger magnus carlson was lucky in
with the way he became challenger
through a mathematical
formula having said that the
format does allow for extraordinary
fighting games
and makes the event such a
tension-filled event i
mean the players must be
must play with their you know hearts you
know pumping
at a heavy heavy rate i mean
fabi was a very impressive
uh challenger right but think of how
remember this guy's the the one that
sergey became the champion remember
we we were literally having a
celebration
uh before the penultimate
game right we thought fabby was like a
75 percent
winner to become a challenger and then
it was a funeral
procession you know everything of course
yeah i thought so i mean and remember he
was like
who was it against peter fiddler that he
missed a clear win
i think he found he fumbled the rook and
bishop win against sidler
yes but and then before that he
did something bad too is it levon
i'm not sure but i'm just saying that
this format
is it's tough on the players it was
it's brutal i would say really guys i
want to look this
ending i like what wang hao did you
didn't have any chances anyway
so all right let's me let me use what i
have as trump's and see
what the situation is so here queen e4
check is another move instead of h3
yeah and test your key and now i want to
play
queen d3 check on the board by the way
queen e4
king f1 i think is the not the only move
you can go f2 what's the problem going
to f2
the problem with f2 is your queen can't
come back okay
so maybe h3 becomes a more forceful move
in that position
okay right queen d three check you said
d3 checks
and now now you know i'm walking into a
g3 idea now i i don't like that one
at all so i guess i gotta go what if i
still play g3 or maybe
maybe i should slide i don't know where
i should go
help me out here i'll ally hunter well
let's just start with let's just pick
one if let's just speak all of them
there's three of them i'm okay
i'm going to play devil's advocate just
because i want to see the win go to the
worst square
yeah let's do that i don't know what the
worst curve is i think i know what the
winds are so we're going to try
we're going to try all of them we're
trying to try to lose
take king e1 how do you actually pick up
anything
no checks on this side
i can there's no e4 that's ever going to
be possible
no no king e1 is the secret bring the
king
to this square and that was giving you
g3
by for free right yeah no no no no we
appreciate it seriously anything can do
to help
be mindful actually if your king is on
g1
and you didn't give me g3 versus in in
this way f2 is better than the king on
g1
because king on g1 you'd be in the you'd
be stuck in that corner
yeah yeah different kind of different
kind of dancing you're gonna need
but this one at least your king is is
safe
safe ish uh where it is so this this is
definitely looking like a better square
in fact
so g3 king e1 looks he did by the way
play
sensibly i want to say i think
uh king f1 i mean
i will in this case after queen d3 play
king e1 i
i hear you i think maybe g3 is not even
a threat but
you know just grand masters are
like this they don't want to give you
anything
i mean i remember i was in argentina it
was great this was fantastic
we were top top grand master tournaments
and everybody
lubo lubomir lavoyevich
liosh portish uh jantima and olfa
anderson we all gave 20 board
simultaneous to children
it was marvelous i i gave i don't know
six draws
you know just just for the kids right i
mean come on
and you know we're having this wonderful
wonderful dinner and
oaf was missing it's like where's old
he's still playing the simultaneous olf
anderson
you know five hours later is still
playing the simultaneous he makes it for
dessert
and i we were like oh what were you
doing he says
i was trying to win control
over the g3 square it's like
grandmasters don't give away anything
like come on like they're kids give them
a try
no no no no no
no no we're like
it was terrible but okay different gm's
different gms have different attitudes
about that as well i remember when i was
coaching
uh a team in harlem back in the 90s the
dark knights
of mott hall and we did fairly well and
we do see
king to e1 as you mentioned so we have
the position on the board and give you
nothing
and so uh they they the team
won some tournaments and you know we're
doing quite well so we got some
notoriety and
we actually got susan polgar to come to
the school uh we got
karpov to come and gary kasparov played
whoa
so we got some big names yeah
uh susan actually taught there so she
was familiar to her no problem
karpov shows up for simon and karpov was
playing the simul and
little aileen espinoza comes dressed
actually it was this color dress that
she had on
she was just all suited up that day it
wasn't school day
she knew she was going to play karpov
karpov's playing this simul and he's
going around and he's whipping and all
the kids he's just destroying them h3
played in the game he's beating all of
them and he gets to aliens position and
it's about move
13. she's alive and he goes
yeah you know let me be a nice let me be
cool
i'll offer you a draw meet yeah so he
offers a draw
and elin looks at him and goes no
[Laughter]
nice
now get out literally okay
so they make a couple more moves
karpov gets like a pawn or something
right he's a little material now
and he's like i'm still going to be nice
and he says draw and by the way takes on
h3 let's play he goes
draw and she goes no he's like
this little girl she's maybe like
10 at the time okay so they play
uh after queenie for a check on the
board right now they play
a few more moves and now karma's up a
piece uh-oh
and uh and it's bad now and she could
see the the vultures circling
and karpov ever the gentleman let's
decide
draw draw last to last chance
okay
[Laughter]
nice can you imagine turning down car
pump
even in like a classical game by you
you one on one but this guy's offering
you a draw and you're like uh uh
you're only up upon uh sorry sorry
anatoly
show me what you got buddy but he didn't
mind
now gary on the other hand
he was like ariel will give you nothing
gary
gary said it very clever no they have to
earn it yeah
this is history we're talking about you
draw the world champion is because you
drew the world champion
gary gave no draws it was boom bing
kill destroy crush that's it right
different players have different
attitudes so alf was
relishing that subtle end game position
narcotic would have given up that draw a
long time ago
i remember as at the st louis chess club
and ben feingold ben had lost a game he
was playing in a swiss
and he was ah he needed to unwind and so
he told me what he had done wrong and
this is a little boy
uh is sitting there watching the game
eyes as big as saucers as we analyze
back and forth ben got all
his frustrations out and i turned to the
little boy
and i said to him would you like to play
a game of chess
he'd he behaved like a perfect gentleman
during our whole
session he goes okay but i've got to
warn you i'm the kindergarten champion
of wisconsin
i said i've been warned
and we have a result guys we do have a
reference draw
as we expected against between kirill
alexenko and
wang hao and that finishes round 11.
what a round but i think anish giving
himself chances with that win against
dingle red we did analyze his tie breaks
they're not pretty but being half a
point behind is much better than a full
point behind
and he's putting that pressure on you
nepamyachi
he's the muslim games wonderful
wonderful and uh tomorrow we'll we'll be
back for
more action as we have these pairings
for round 12
all set up and it's like every day the
pairings become
more and more crucial guys i think it's
a huge game
tomorrow between fabi and anish
absolutely fabi
against anish all eyes on this one
but don't forget nepon actually with the
black pieces against
wong hao will wang khao try to press
will he be able to
that's going to be an important one as
well meanwhile ding learn against
christchurch
i'm sorry i don't see either one of
these people really vying for first
place in this tournament
mvl you said it has like a really
outside chance but it starts
with beating alex cinco tomorrow is he
going to be able to do it the russian
player had a disaster
against nepaliachi but besides that he's
been in a kind of solid role and not
easy to beat
at all uh can mvl do it him himself has
not shown
the strength that we're used to from him
he has calculated well
but at the end of the day the results
have not been there minus two in the
last four games that
that's not good that is not good at all
[Music]
so we'll stand by for just a second we
might have somebody join us
yes sir what do you think are the
chances realistically of
it not being nepo no nepo is just
he's looking so good and again as we've
mentioned before his immediate pursuer
on each gary losing on a tie break means
that he's still maintaining
for all realistic one one-point lead
um yeah he's maybe as high as
75 percent at this moment to be
challenging to magnus carlson
yeah i was thinking about the same
number seventy five eight
same number yeah but what if what if he
loses a game
well then
they take a nosedive his stalker
i mean you guys are saying he's going to
play against wang hao
always a dangerous customer max a very
motivated maxine bashir lacrosse
and a potentially awake ding lorraine in
the last round i'll
of course dig loren is a question mark
but
do you see a potential loss out of
any of these three games well the
problem
is it's nepal himself i mean he's
mercurial
he he can play incredibly fast
and like just oops blunder uh
so you know it it all depends if
if he decides that he's just going to
play the best chess
he's ever played and become challenger
you just tip your hat
what does that mean he's ever played
like he going which is
good solid no i i don't think he's going
to
be looking for draws not in that sense
rather i think he's going to be saying
hey i want to play for an advantage
i'm playing for an advantages and if my
opponents are going to collapse
like carol did against me that's
that's on them that's not on me uh he
knows
uh he can taste this multi-million
dollar match in dubai at the end of the
year
and he wants what is what does it mean
he's a again he's a fantastic player
he's won major events before
no question about it he's got nerves
up the yin yang however that said
he's never vied for a world championship
this is a candidate this will be
something that he puts in his is
his pocket for the rest of his life his
moment is here
what do you feel about this is the
question i have for you what do you
think about
the nerves factor this is the x factor
do you think you will have any right now
well this is the point this is his
first candidates he he this is his
rookie
debut right and he's making the most out
of it and he's impressed everybody even
when
even though yeah he lost the last game
of the first half but hey he's he was
plus three going into that game so
yeah he's impressed everybody and as far
as i can tell
in the second half help me out here
aleandro
i don't see a problem i has he made any
missteps
no he's playing well he's playing fast
as
usual i think he's just taking the
chances that he's given
he isn't over pressing game against any
gear in the first round okay he was
white he didn't think that he was a
must win game play some sort of solids
fashion cup with the white side and
didn't risk too much
he took his chances against alexenko
easily
did really really well um
[Music]
yeah today's game i mean also with the
white pieces should i take any risks
nope let's exchange
all the pieces i've used up my whites
and
i i just don't see him being in bad form
and sometimes about nepo he's a streaky
player
but he's not shaking he's not shaking
right now at all
and he's playing against some players
that let's face it you play
ding loren on round 14 guys checked out
i mean
it's different than when dinglerand
played fabio on round three right you're
still
trying to get back in the tournament but
round 14 you're in last place
and you you play the leader what are you
really playing for right and that's
gonna
affect the huge i mean there's a
difference in the preparation that you
could take into a game
that matters for the championship title
and we're like
you're either eighth or tied for seventh
is that really going to make a
difference
well listen guys i'm hearing you i'm
hearing you
say you're ready to bet uh the farm
on nepo 80 percent clearly and clearly
he's
he's the leader there's like what can we
do you guys are point ahead of
everybody else at the moment so the
narrative looks clear nepo's tournament
to lose
however he was plus three after six
games in the first half of the
tournament
and lost round seven so let's see if he
can
avoid that misstep because if he does
it's his tournament and he will be
challenging magnus for the
big prize money when we get to dubai but
still
three rounds to go with some hot chasers
right now
it all will start tomorrow we'll see
what happens is these pairings mean
so much so much on the line and
still at least three people with large
hopes that they can do it yeah thank you
absolutely and we see again
those pairings they're going to be huge
guys join us tomorrow
as we cast these games karana against
gary we just can't miss it you know he's
had a year to prepare and
he must bring an idea must fabiano
caruana to win that game for him for
sure
do or die it's been a pleasure
i can't wait until tomorrow i agree
and i hope we'll see you all maurice
alejandro
always a pleasure to call the action
with you both
[Music]
you